Když to projdu,
tak bychom aspoň minimálně s iticem si
dali nějakou schůzku chráštěnech.
Prošli jsme si znova ten plac,
definovali jsme si jako přesně to místo.
Potvrdil tu stavební přípravu.
Doladili si nějaký poslední detaily?
Tam teda s itekem jsme teďka kompletně
jako připravený.
Oni nám dovezli ten prototyp tý antény,
takže jsme si ji mohli trošku jako ošahat
a hlavně naměřit její uchycení.
Takže elektro připravený máme údržba je
ready.
O vláďovi hrnkovi jsem to předával to s
tou anténou, takže ten ten řekl,
že s tím jako nemají problém,
že si s tím poradí kluci a ty datové
zásuvky, jak jsem zmiňoval,
se jsem včera dostal info od Martina
Čecha, že jsou dodané.
Nemyslím to zle jenom si to ještě jako
zítra ověřim,
až budu zase zpátky v práštěnech.
Co se tady teďka bude dít,
tak zejďte mě čekat ta kontrola stavební
připravenosti datovejch sítí apetack nám
bude prodávat ty brány tam máme dodací
lhůtu apeg říká,
že jsou teoreticky schopný reagovat v
rámci dnů.
Já budu radši počítat nějakej ten tejden
a na to se pak bude navazovat teda ta
další další kroky,
jako je instalace připojení a to už
konečný zahájení toho testování,
jak který tak dlouho čekáme.
Lidi.
Já jsem tam tam teda ještě extra teda
přidal kvůli tomu,
že to je oftrack jenom tu sekci dole toho
dopadu.
To teda to posutí těch willstonů tam tu
stavební přípravu tedy posouvám.
Na příští tejden na pondělí.
Zítra si to projdu, jestli to zejtra.
Potvrdím,
že ty informace sedí tak to ještě jenom
tak to ještě jenom přidám na údržbu a ta
stavební příprava je teda v tom případě
hotová.
Na základě toho hned objednám ty brány,
dávám si tam nějakej ten tejden leattime
toho dodání a tím pádem si myslím,
že už toho patnáctýho definitivně to
budeme mít nejenom dodané i nainstalované
a zprovozněné a.
A můžeme začít,
takže tohle je ten teďka ten náš defekt.
Já se budu teda psát, takže chápu správně.
Golive je patnáctýho 5.
To bude to to bude to doinstalování.
Ten gal ten kolos si řekněme toho 18 jo
ten pátek 15. Vychází pátek, takže 18.
A půl,
když to je poznámky promiň jo a potom
vlastně TD ty palety od plastu a takový
ty věci nebo ten druhej dodavatel,
to jste odpískali nebo jak to mám tady.
Jo jsme odpískali. Já si myslím,
že to bude mít menší jako dobrou zprávu
pak pro Davida kupce zita to s ním
proberu já ty palety na mě ty,
co jsou pro nás jako na technologicky
blbý.
Jo,
ale a vy nějak teda budete mít stále
zajištěný takový ty 2 typy paleb nebo tak
něco?
Máme máme 2 typ palet,
který máme od toho českého dodavatele.
Ty jsou naprosto v pořádku,
jsou i otagované připravené o štítkované.
Všechno je hotové, ty jsou reddit go,
takže ty palety jsou na místě,
jenom čekají, až začneme to testování.
Dobře, takže ale nicméně stále platí,
že ten typ projektů je takovej spíš ne
úplně klíčovější,
ale na nic tu hned nebo tak něco.
Jo to platí.
Ano takovej takovej takovej takovej rende
no.
Jo jo chápu chápu koukej tady.
Jo jo my si to vyzkoušíme,
my si to vyzkoušíme s tím dudym
dodavatelem,
takže ten projekt nám to jako v
uvozovkách neovlivníme. Si myslím,
že dokážeme stále jako dosáhnout toho,
co chceme,
což je primárně otest toho to FID vidím
tam jako nějakej vedlejší pozitivní efekt,
že by nám ty palety mohly i ulehčit
nějakým problémům,
co s nima máme na dopasu tím,
že ty pastový palety jsou pevnější a drží
lépe tu kostru,
takže ten projekt nám to jako neohrozí,
jenom je to trošku takovej projektovej
jako bullshit, no co řešíte víc?
S kterým jsem nečekal.
Chápu chápu takovej appendix.
Dobře, hele prosím tě, když půjdu,
jako sem dobře, tak ty rizika si tady 3.
Jako řeknou, to je dobrý.
Tady asi posunutý dopad,
to je super a jenom tady prosím tě.
Na to drát nějaké řešení jsme se sladili
a už nezachráníme. To znamená,
nedej tam bude, ale řešení existuje,
tak chápu.
Jo to je to je ten to je ten ten dopad je
pak ten výsledek toho, co nezachráníme.
Jo a tady si ověří ještě,
jestli ten ty datový podklady potřeby
Jo.
jsou tam na místě? Jo.
Ano ano.
A když, a když ne, tak co?
Na ty teďka nechci ani přemýšlet.
Jo už nemám. Nemám možnost řešit. Věřím,
že tady ta příroda ty zásuvky budou
takový, jaký jsem chtěl na tom místě,
kde jsem chtěl.
Ale jestli ne tak příští tejden ve středu
tady budeme mít no,
tak jestli tam ty zásuvky nebudou tak
příští týden ve středu tady budou
To znamená.
znamenat statusu stejně s dalšíma strakem.
No.
Znamená to, že tady, když tady budu?
Ale já.
Já pevně věřím tomu,
že umíme dodat zásuvky.
OK.
Já jenom kdyby tam třeba nebyli,
nechci malovat,
tak jenom jestli to má dopad jako sám víš
tady do toho.
To to určitě bude mít no.
Hele pojďme se dohodnout,
když zítra něco zjistíš a bude to špatný,
tak mě dej, prosímtě, hned vědět.
OK domluveno.
A nějaký dopad jo? Protože o to,
protože tam jsou teďka závisí nějaký jako
nějaký prostě strkačky ohledně.
IT potřeb jako těch datových potřeb,
tak jenom,
abychom měli ještě další informace,
děkuji.
Já když půjdu sem, tak prosím tě, hele,
svítím tady červeně připravuju zpracování
toto.
Err jo já.
To platí teda jo to platí teda v kontextu
toho.
Tam, jak já bych to jako řekl, ano,
že to platí za Tomáš jako to,
co připravit mohl připravený má a Tomáš
teďka vlastně jenom čeká,
až mu dodáme ty tamtény,
abys to mohl otestovat,
takže tohle za mě jako stále platí,
že je OK.
Staveb okolo čtvrtýho 5.
Jenom prosím tě kliknu jenom sem jo
čtvrtýho 5 to tam máme,
to tam platí ne čtvrtýho 5.
Jo tak já jsem jo,
tak já jsem si to předtím nepřesunul.
Jenom asi v lasaně. Jo OK,
tak to je to to to platí a ta instalace
No dobře.
A čtvrtýho 5. Právě.
ta patnáctýho.
Pardon dobré teda 15.
15.
Ty kráso dobře, u kartorát jsem.
Dobře, dám si to sem no.
Tak to dobře.
O ty roky a dlouho je strana 18 to
souhlasí? Myslím že jo to souhlasí ale.
Prostoru.
Obřad jo tak jenom tady díky za ty rizika
a ten dopad,
což je super AS tím Martinem všechen
deník, prosím tě vidět jenom buďto OK má,
Hmm.
nebo prostě teda jo.
Jo OK zita zita vědět.
Tak.
A to nějak u sebe skonsoliduje tak super
dopravníková síť v chráštěrech.
Tak.
Tak to je jsme na tom tady jsme na tom
bych řekl obráceně.
Co je tam?
Tady jsme na tom pěkně.
Stavební příprava v rámci SHZ stavováků
všechno šlo dle plánu, tam mi řekli,
že to šlo poměrně hladce.
Všechno proběhlo dobře. Příprava prostoru,
invetura materiálu máme hotovou prostor,
máme prostor, prostor na plac,
máme seřazeným materiály in metodizovanej
taky máme mám potvrzený třeba teďkem
teďka před před nějakou půl hoďkou,
že to je OK adle,
teda toho plánu jsme dvacátýho sedmýho
tady v pondělí začali s aicomem.
Zahájili tu stavbu těch dopravníků.
Co se tady teda bude potom dít dále.
Tady šestnáctýho 4 pan palý nebo?
Ježíš.
Ne pardon, pardon to to jsem to byl,
to byl copy pass, to tam vůbec bejt nemá.
Pardon, omlouvám se, omlouvám se,
co se teda bude dít,
Aha OK.
tak další bod je stavební příprava avapsu
tam já to doteď nevnímám jako jako riziko,
je to jenom nějaká jako věc,
která se nestala úplně. Dle plánu to bylo,
že minulý týden v pátek jsme tu díru měli
mít připravenou,
nějak jsme se jako blbě pochopili nebo
shodli,
to je asi teď jako 1 ta díra tam prostě
jako není.
Já jsem sališem se o tom včera byl.
Vynasnažíme se jako s avapsem dohodnout,
aby nám to teda do toho příštího týdne
dodělali. Pokud to dodělají,
tak pro nás nemá žádnej vliv.
Tím pádem je ten problém vyřešený.
Už jsme i teda připravený ještě v rámci
nějakýho plán base notreckem na
alternativu, že se to nestihne.
Potvrzovali jsme si, že v případě,
že ten avabs nebude na část,
tak my máme nějakej plán jen b,
kde jinde můžeme mezitím stavět,
takže my o ten čas nepřijdeme.
Je to jenom zase nějakej,
Jo.
řekněme organizační opruz,
se kterým jsme jako nepočítali,
to je ten důvod, proč to není v riziku.
Je to za mě jenom informativní.
Další bod je vyklizení regálu,
to je takovej upravenej stranovej
požadavek. Já jsem na to,
já jsem na to dneska prostor Davida kupce,
že tam ještě potřebujeme nějaký ještě
extra regál,
jenom dočasně vyklidit za zdí mezi 4 FA 1
FV tom posledním patře na příští týden,
aby tam kluci mohli nějakým způsobem
pohodlně.
Když to řeknu špatně postavit dopravník,
jakmile ho tam postaví a budou to mít
připravený,
tak regály se zase budou moct vrátit,
to teda minimálně aspoň ta 1 strana.
Davidovi jsem to sepisoval specifikoval.
Bylo to.
Ano, davide.
Bude hotovo.
Super super díky moc, díky moc.
Takže to je vlastně jako demontáž a
opětovaná montáž?
Ano ano je to jenom prostě dočasný
prostor,
aby se tam dal ten dopravník dobře
uchytit a pak pak tam mám ať zpátky s
Davidem s Davidem to máme vyměněný.
Jo.
Je to tak nastavení DMS,
tady máme nějak tady,
máme nějaké domluvení o zaření zařazení
do té fronty je duerka s tím,
že teda další další člověk od nějakého
updatu bychom měli mít za nějaký nějaký
teďka 2 týdny.
Tam jsou nějaký pravidelný checky,
myslím 1 za měsíc,
kdy se tady to prochází,
takže to to je další věc,
co nás teďka bude čekat.
Ten Martin martie martíky že jo má s tím
Pavlem tý schůzky,
to je ono viď ten check to je ono.
Ano.
Ano ano ano tady náš front front leader.
OK.
Tak.
Jo jo.
A.
A příští týden fu,
to je nás čeká až nějakej czech,
sinotecamp nás myslím měl Lukáše ohledně
napojení toho jižního sjezdu na přít na
odtah transferselu a následně její
napojení na té jižní AT.
A to je pátýho 5 ne to je pátýho 5 víte
vy asi ne.
Ano to je pátýho 5 pardon.
Jo jo.
Se omlouvám až dneska není můj den.
V, podívej se, co dál,
něco mezi těma takovým čtvrtkem chápu.
Hele,
tady vlastně a tady ten člověk jenom co
konkrétně prosím?
Jenom si jakoby jak to je napojený jako.
Jo, je to rozhodně napojený,
je tam ohledně toho,
jak aktuálně bude připravený to napojení
v návaznosti na.
Jak to máme nějaký interní slang,
jako tomu říkáme vánočka je tam ohledně
Dobrý den.
jako budoucího jako přepojení nebo
přetrasování těch toků? Jo.
Jo.
No ať máme i kompatibilitu zařízenou.
Hele a.
Až pátýho 5.
To znamená oni vlastně jako stavili a až
pátýho pátýho až vytušej.
Ne jak to vlastně udělali? Ne,
tak se na to na místě.
Určitě určitě,
tohle je check na nějakou jako budoucí
nástavbu. Co já se na to bude věnovat?
Je to jako task, co děláme dopředu,
abychom na to byli připravený.
Dobře.
Se omlouvám možná to není.
OK.
Možná to není úplně nejlíp sepsaný.
Ono to v mojí vydává smysl.
Fajn.
Jo rizika zůstávají stejné,
jako jsem zmiňoval minulý týden.
Víte, jakoby ten finální budoucnost?
Ještě mi vypad.
Pacifiky.
A.
Seš tam.
Já už tě slyším tě ano.
Jo jo rizika jsou stejný a nějaký ten
dopad bývá o nich.
Nebo co?
Já se omlouvám, jestli můžu,
je to vyprávět jenom mě, tak se omlouvám.
Rizika jsou stejné z toho důvodu tak
jinak. Pardon,
rizika jsou stejné jako minulý týden ten.
Ano.
Ano vašku.
Poslouchám no.
Jo, já jsem vypadával Vašek,
jenom mě je to problém u mě,
nebo to máte ostatní také?
Ne.
IIU mě.
Ta, Praha.
Poslouchám.
No tak ještě 1 tak ty.
Halo halo.
Ano vypadáváš na vašku?
Nevypadalo, já svojím tady.
Plyn a teď mě slyšíš.
Ano teď ano teď super.
Haló haló.
A tak rád už říct na opeře tak povídej a
povídej rizika dopadl.
Tak.
Rizika stejné jako minulý týden dopad v
tuto chvíli.
Jako za mě není jako reálný.
My ten problém dokážeme vyřešit jenom v
tuhle chvíli nedokážeme jako říct,
kdy kapacity s otvíráním TC ta ta to 1
riziko nevnímáme jako úplně,
že by mělo mít nějaký drastický dopad.
Myslíme si spíš jako, že nebude mít žádný.
Každopádně teďka nás to netrápí,
jelikož stejně jednotek na to nebude mít
čas se podívat dříve.
Než v červnu.
Takže to riziko je sice jako bude v
budoucnu existovat,
ale za mě ještě to není relevantní.
Je to jenom bod na který myslet 2 bod
rizika určitě jako dopad pro nás bude mít
drastický, pokud to nevyřešíme,
ale já věřím tomu, že to jako vyřešíme.
Jo, to nastavení těch tras,
na co potřebujeme dělat,
máme teďka identifikovanou nějakou,
řekněme nějaké zlepšení na utilizaci do
pasa, abychom se dostali zpátky do toho.
Do toho zadání.
Nebo do toho stavu, který jsme očekávali,
že bude jsme jako stoprocentně
přesvědčení jako nějakým předběžným,
jako přepočtem, že to zvládneme.
Teď to jenom potřebujem to jenom
potřebujem udělat. Jo,
my se bavíme jako o situaci,
že musíme mít to do pasu někdy jako do
léta vyřešený a teďka v tuhle chvíli jako
nedokážem říct, že to zvládneme činné.
Já si jako myslím, že ano,
že ty jako updaty nejsou až tak jako
dramatický.
Ale nechci teď,
jako si jako mazat med kolem pusy jo,
takže nevíme jenom to riziko známe.
Ale.
Tady máte,
potřebujeme zkontrolovat a případně
upravit. Jak přijdeme? Sorry,
a to nastane,
kdy to už je nebo co to byla?
Ano ano.
Potřebujete zkontrolovat.
To už se to už se děje.
My teďka tu situaci s Lukášem známe tu
potřebu na tu úpravu taky známe.
Včera jsme na tohohle konto vlastně
dělali nějakou 1 zkoušku u ropasu v rámci
úpravy jako třídění a tohle,
jako je ještě určitě věc,
která jako nějakou dobu poteče.
Ok.
Jestliže to víte, hele,
to se bude asi kvalifikovat dneska do tý
cesty. Ne, to se bude přizpůsobovat, viď.
Teď jsem tě, nepochopil promiň ještě 1.
Na spodní práci to nebude jako že je to
nastavím a mám to a to bude průběžně jako
nějaký že jo.
To nic ne vyřešení vyzkoušíte.
Ano ano, jo, ano, ano ano ano, přesně tak.
Jo.
Takovej takovej fightoning průběžnej.
Ano.
Dobře.
Takže.
Jinými.
Pardon,
představuji tady doprava s mozkem to
platí.
Já teďka ani nevidím,
že si překliknu obrazovku ašku.
Taky ne.
Velkou část mě tam nějaká alpence.
Teď by tam měly excel s těmi.
Stále vidíme nasanu.
To.
A tvůj hlas taky skáče kvalitně.
Já se n tady.
Já se budu ptát dopravníku do 19. 6.
Obecně milníky stále z číny,
co platí a jsme online.
Já myslím, že Vašek online není.
Ašku.
Takže jo jo.
Pardon.
Vašek online není no.
Je ale jenom Windows za sekundu.
Co tady?
To se tady děje.
Ve škole mi tě fakt vůbec neslyšíme,
je to jako prostě vůbec skoro.
A teďka má od vás.
Teď už se nesekám.
Teď už se neseká teď už dobrý.
Pardon já se fakt snažím co nejrychleji
ještě stručnější,
abych tady zdržoval frontu no.
Nejde ti to.
Já vím, já se já se snažím.
A teď haló haló.
Je to lepší.
Možná.
Ano.
Mluvit.
A vám je to opravdu.
Takže hezky?
Dobrý jo ty vole to je hrozný dneska.
Tak teď Filip vidíš.
Ne.
Ledabyho to.
Ne.
Nabíhá to teď vidím teamsy.
Teamse.
Fiborek.
Tak co?
Pixel.
Jo.
Dobře sladěný Lukáši.
Íme.
Krása.
Tak.
Všechno platí, jo?
Tady.
Posílám.
Ano ano všechno platí.
Třeba.
Já jsem tady dvakrát i do těch začátek
jsem dal hotovo. Jo.
Jo super.
To.
Ty rizika,
který tam jsou tak bez dopadu na gola.
Dobře.
Můžeme.
Zdravotnic teda pardon oživení zapojení
transferce, ale něco k tomu.
A je to how to.
Jenom rychle krátký update je to stále on
holt ale začali jsme se stavební
přípravou, prošli jsme s Alešem,
předali jsme a už připravujeme tadyty.
Okolnostní věci před zahájením toho
projektu, takže to běží.
Aktuálně brzy vizte zatím nevíme,
viď asi indikovaný.
Ne zatím zatím nic nemáme.
Nic.
Já jenom podívám co sem rychle o ony ty
termíny jsou většinou u květen.
A dvavacátýho osmýho září je golive.
To zůstává dobře, tak a poslední robot.
Stále ontrack dobře.
Pro babi.
Ano.
Tak robopic tady ten týden,
tedy podle plánu běžíme s tím očekávaným
zatěžovacím testem, řekněme od pondělka,
která se snažíme těch 8 hodin v kuse na
obou stanicích. Neříkám,
že se nám to jako ve stoprocentech
případů jako úplně vždycky daří.
Ještě sem tam tam nějaký jako fantuning
děláme,
ale pro mě primárně ten ten úkol nebo
úloha toho týdne,
jako je splněná ty stanice si myslím,
že dostávají docela.
Dobře naloženo, tak, takže tohle běží.
Měli jsme s Martinem kišem nějaký nějaký
sing,
kde jsme si sing předávali nějaké ty
taski na nějakou optimalizaci a nějaký
fintu,
co nás nevyhnutelně jako do budoucna bude
čekat.
Jsou to ze mě spíš jako obecný věci,
který.
S kterejma se budem potýkat ještě dále i
po golifu a je to řekněme nějaká taková
ta dobrá pravidelná údržba,
nebo jako hygiena technologická,
na který budeme muset makat? Martin kyš,
to já vlastně?
Bude product on do toho robot,
takže my se na tohle konto vlastně
kosinkujeme. Předáváme si to za mě,
jakoby ta hlavní technologická funkční
část je jako téměř hotová.
Možná teďka ladíme fakt jako poslední
procenta a pak ten zbytek už bude jako
přecházet dále.
Enhnm.
Sinkovali jsme se také ohledně teda
nějaký tý budoucí spolupráce projektů,
procesů.
Abysme si vsadili ty tazky s Michalem
sežinem tady nějakou tu představu,
co by se mělo v těch fajn unzích dělat?
Jak by se ta stanice jako měla udržovat,
ladit a primárně jak řešit?
Chyby nebo úroveň a počet erodů jsou
stanicí a nějaký to jako základní
rozdělení,
co bude jako dodané v rámci projektu,
co v rámci jako Martina a co potom
potřebujeme,
aby byla nějaká jako pravidelná ta údržba?
Údržba nebo hygiena tím procesem?
Místním jo,
takže to to máme přidaný od příštího
týdne,
teda na to konto vlastně budu začínat i
nějaké zaškolení ještě extra procesáku z
toho, co se teda obecně bude dít zítra,
teda je velký den, d systém,
jak se ten tester oppicu z toho dorazí
vlastně i ten celý projektový tým se
reaktu zítřejší den, teda bude ten den,
kdy ten robot opět pojede stejným
způsobem,
zase těch 8 hodin v kuse na obě stanice s
tím rozdílem,
že z tohoto dne se vlastně veškerá data
budou podrobně procházet a validovat.
Zdali teda.
V rámci JPI jsme jako dosáhli té
očekávané produktivity a úspěšnosti.
Co od toho očekáváme? Pokud ano,
tak samozřejmě v tu chvíli je to nějaký i
právní předpoklad pro pro převzetí stanic.
Já teď jako říkám,
že ten předpoklad je na 99% ano,
protože my sledujeme a víme,
jak ty data jako od pondělka vypadají a
minimálně z toho jako právního hlediska,
co sereact má umět dodat.
A co ten robot za jejich stranu má dělat,
tak to oni poměrně vlastně jako splňují.
Abysme se tady jako nemazali med kolem
pusy.
Ať to jako řekneme,
jak ta situace je ta stanice jako není
ještě stabilní v tom ohledu,
že bysme jako mohli jet 24,
7 a nemít tam člověka to tak určitě není,
ale hodně těch problémů, nebo chyb,
který se tam dějou,
tak si už jako způsobem sami.
Je to primárně asi jako teďka. Ten způsob,
jakým ukládáme to zboží zboží dominu na
příjmu je to 1.
Z těch jako řekněme hlavních pilotních
tásků,
co teďka pro Martina budou poměrně jako
hodně podobná pracovat a spolupracovat v
rámci jako procesu a provozů.
Takže to jen abysme si jako řekli,
jak ta situace reálná je,
že tady jako není svět jako růžovej.
Za předpokladu tedy,
že zítra dokončíme to esej t úspěšně,
což teda předpokládám, že ano,
je to pro nás teda nějakej další
předpoklad pro objednávání robotů do s
dosaze s tam ty projekty,
řekněme v přípravný fázi paralelně běží,
abychom neztráceli čas a budeme doufat,
že IV tomhle budeme nějakým způsobem teda
úspěšní.
Jakmile ten gól live, jak řekneme,
jakmile to předání proběhne,
tak příští týden se chci začít jako
nějakým způsobem už více zabývat a
připravovat na předání do provozu.
Jo tam tam ujišťuju ještě jenom pro
Davida, že to není o to,
že v pondělí začínáme golive.
Ptáme tam ještě 1 jako IT restík,
kterej si myslím,
že definitivně tomu golive brání.
Je to ohledně nastavení nebo řekněme
otvírání nebo managování portu přes VMS
nebo přes případně přes přes přes k
jedničku.
Martin kyš se na to dneska dneska bude
sinkovat. Zjistíme, jaká je ta situace,
kdy by to mohlo být dodělané.
Každopádně si myslím,
že to pro nás znamená příští týden
krásnou příležitost jako tak to.
Tlačítko připravovat, říct si,
co a jak připravit si to zaškolení a
domluvit si nějakej ten termín,
kdy budeme chtít jako opravdu provozně
ten op ik spustit,
ať to ať to za mě máme připravené a
děláme to, děláme to správně.
A pak ten poslední bod jsem vlastně už
jako zmínil, zmínil vlastně předtím.
Mám tam ještě 1 bod,
pak na sebe nějakej design nebo přípravu
nějaký ty bezpečnostní desky? My víme,
že v pohybu toho robota mezi těma portama
jsou nějaký mezery mezi těma portama,
kde má zboží v případě,
že robotovi vypadne tendenci propadnout,
už se nám samozřejmě stalo. Myslím,
že ve 4 případech jsme to zboží bohužel
zničili,
protože se prostě rozfákalo o tu podlahu,
takže.
Mám předomluvený s údržbou a zítra se
půjdeme podívat na to.
Jak bychom tam mohli dát nějakou desku s
nějakou měkčenou pěnou nebo něčím
takovýmhle, aby v případě,
že robot nějakým způsobem selže nebo
udělá chybu tak,
aby to zboží aspoň spadlo do něčeho
měkkýho a my jsme ho nemuseli jako
vyšortovávat v inventurách.
Jo, hlavně.
Toť asi k těm dvoum stanicím.
Hele rizika teda žádný tady tady to zní
jako nadějně. Jo, a já se teda zeptám, jo,
co tady to ještě mám? 1 interní task,
který tomu brání, co co tohle?
Jo, to je to téma toho,
že potřebujeme mít jako možnost si ty
porty otvírat a managovat přes konzoli.
To v tuhle chvíli nefunguje.
Je to ještě stále dělaný manuálně přímo
jako týmem eduar a určitě jako v reálném
provozu nemůžeme jako chtít,
aby se jako provoz komunikoval napřímo
jako s nějakým člověkem a furt neustále
ho prosil o otvírání zavírání,
takže to je ten náš terestík a Martin kyš
dneska?
Má tady to konto sing SK jedničkou jak na
tom jsme a kdy to kdy to jsme schopni
jako do té.
K jedničky zavést.
Tak to je k.
1 hele a když to nestihnou, je to průser.
Je to problém.
Není, není.
Můžeme bez toho žít, jo fungovat.
Tohle pro nás jako není předpoklad,
že to jako stanice jako převzít jo.
No chápu, ale potom ten David chudák.
Prodá se to.
Dá se to nás to předpokládat jako k
zahájení toho provozu v rámci golifu.
Vpravo.
A pokud nám jako konzole řekne,
že budou připravený,
Jo.
až já nevím příští týden ve středu,
tak se prostě jako s Davidem domluvíme na
pane se tam příští tejden na středu já
jako já to nevnímám jako jako životně,
jako potřebnou věc.
Když teďka si pár dní dáme volno a
Jo.
začneme ten koulej pozdějc já si myslím,
že nám to jako paradoxně dá jenom
benefitně víc času se jako na to pořádně
připravit IS tím provozem a procesem.
Klidně se mnou nesouhlasíte?
Tu aplikaci řekl krásně,
že jako teda by se případně posunul
golife, když.
To nestihne.
Nebo.
Ano.
Správně.
A potenciálně ano.
Dobře.
No, pokud to nic neohrozí, teďka si řekl,
že ne.
Tak tak asi OK jed David s ním on bude
jako v pohodě.
Tak.
A potom prosím tě ještě.
Máme ještě 1 ze zadní dotaz,
já jsem tady jsem tady je, to je promiň.
Jseš tam.
Já se omlouvám jako to jak to, jak je to,
jak je to napsaný tak jako úplně není.
Provozně bez toho provozně bez toho
nemůžeme fungovat.
A.
Aha.
Jo.
Ok no.
Takže co z toho vyplývá to?
Fungovat fungovat nemůžeme jako oficiálně.
To samozřejmě v tom případě jako impact
na golive má.
Ten provozní,
kdyby to jako řekněme jako už provoz jako
obsluhoval. Já za mě jako jenom říkám,
že to není nějaký jako úplně velký terno,
protože jestli toho robota zapneme v
pondělí nebo v úterý, nebo ve středu,
si myslím,
že už jako pro nás teďka jako nějaký
zásadní jako dopad v tuto chvíli nemá
klidně, jako se mnou nesouhlaste.
Jestli ten názor je špatnej,
ale myslím si,
Jo jo.
že to jako nějak kritická záležitost v
tuto chvíli není.
Není to hyglocker jo.
Tak.
Tak vám píšu.
Tak dobrý.
Děkuji.
Tak a ještě se ptám, prosím tě,
tady budou nějaký asi starší kritéria?
Všechno to si odškrtáte podepíšete a
přidáte jo tady v rámci sedantu.
Ano.
Dobře.
2 otázka je TDD tam byl nějaký?
Teda nevím jestli jestli to nevíš jedu
teďka Martina vikišovi nebo ruce nějaký
prostor,
že se to natěsno že nebo nikam nedosáhne?
To mám nechat Martinovi to téma nebo mám
se ptát tebe.
Ne, ne, ne, to je řešený.
To už to už je dořešené.
Tak potom mi řekne, jak se to vyřešili,
to musím projekty, prostě to bude dobro.
A když dobře, takže rizika žádný.
A když půjdu jenom jsem rychle promiň
takhle roboty, jo.
Tak v podstatě tohleto všechno bys tam
třeba 4.
Tak to bude splněný teda.
Ano.
100.
Já říkám, že ano.
Super hele a mimochodem,
kde se to budou ty čísla skladovat
normálně v konzoli to bude vidět
vytáhnout z konzole nebo kde to bude.
My my ty informace máme zalogovaný IV
konzoli,
asi to jako není úplně uživatelský,
jako přátelský prostředí. Myslím si,
že to je v tuhle chvíli jako něco,
co dokážeme jako managovat pouze jako já
a Martin, ale my ty jako informace víme,
kde jsou a zpracovat si je umíme zároveň
ty stejný informace jsou potom dostupný
na sedacký platformě,
kde oni je taky mají a zpracovávají.
V tuto chvíli teda taky zatím tam je
A jak často?
přístup jenom pro mě a pro Martina.
Jo.
Ta frekvence ta frekvence se jakoby
stahování nebo náhledu ta frekvence na ty
data.
V případě se reaktů je to jako real time.
Je to online a říkám,
zatím je tam jako jenom pro mě a pro
Martina přístup z důvodu toho,
že musíme zeškolit i jako případně jiný
lidi.
Z hlediska konzole je to on dement,
to znamená kdy já nebo Martin do toho
vlezeme a zpracujem si to.
A Filip a ten přírovej stav je takhle
nechat ho být,
nebo to trošku jako se automatizovat
ondiment kdykoliv stav cího není.
To si to si jako určitě dostat
zautomatizujeme, ale v tuhle chvíli víme,
že jako ta sadea k platforma jako
existuje v realtimu budem používat asi
primárně jí pro ty pro ty náhledy a potom
do budoucna si jako určitě vytvoříme,
jak je automatizovaný interní náhled,
ale asi v tuhle chvíli nemá pro nás smysl
pálit čas. Pokud ten seriál to má,
tak je to nechme jako dodělat my s
Martinem spíš teďka jenom kontrolujeme,
že ty data, který oni mají a prezentujou,
sedí s tím, co máme my.
Nějaký jako 1 otazníky diskripencí jsme
našli a kontrolujeme SS raktem a ano,
No.
Jo.
potom do budoucna se to třeba
zautomatizujeme i my u nás.
A prosím tě jenom teda, že jo,
pak se rozhodneme vo ty další ramena dál
že jo 7 5 to asi platí ne to sedmýho
pátýho se asi rozhodnete ne to platí.
Ano doufám.
Děkuju.
Hele a oni některá část voda asi na
Slovensko? Viď ty ramena.
Ano 6.
No a tam nějakej okamžik dojdou v čase
asi ještě letos a tam vlastně potom ten
způsob toho sledování bude úplně stejný,
jako to dáme v Čechách.
Přes ten portál se reaktůjou nebo to už
bude vytuněný jinak?
AA tak daleko tak daleko jsme si myslím,
že jsme ještě jako nepřemejšleli.
Takže portál sedá jak to tam definitivně
a 100% bude a to jestli to budeme mít
vytunění my teď jako nedokážu říct.
Jo jo já se jenom ptám,
vlastně co vlastně pro nás Slovensko copy
pased nebo trošku vyplněná verze?
Jenom se ptám jakože.
To.
Takhle, jako když to, když to,
když to zjednoduším,
Co.
tak na Slovensku půjde copypayst ale
cokoliv jako co pro ty roboty budeme
dělat by mělo být jako poměrně jednoduše
transferovatelný mezi těma tepama.
Dobře, dobře dobře. Jo,
já si to vem vzhůru,
nějaký harmonizace dobré.
Tohle je čtvrtýho 5, který nechávám.
Super.
Skvělý.
To je asi všechno, děkuju,
já to jenom tady probouknu.
To je asi všechno na tebe,
jestli potřebuješ jít, tak.
Dobře.
Propuštěn tedy děkujeme.
Jo jestli nemáte otázky,
tak děkuju teda děkuju teda mockrát a
mějte se.
Díky.
Čau.
Tak ten kone bratrle můžeme na tebe.
Tradiční otázka.
Ahoj, může,
já jsem chtěla poděkovat ještě Filipovi
za stručný souhrn.
Super.
Máš 4 4 hele rozložení zásoby z celé
název trační otázka,
co tady necháme zatím spát?
Nemám tam nic ne, nemám tam nic zapsanýho.
Každopádně teď se čeká ještě na schůzku,
kterou já jsem zaplánovala pozdě a už je
naplánovaná na pondělí.
A pak pak to začnu reportovat už tady,
každopádně se bude řešit,
že se čas vlastně zásob přesune na
Slovensko a jedná se.
Aktuálně by se jednalo o okolnění části
číny. Víc k tomu teďko říkat.
Čína, Chinaski.
Přesně China víc tomu teďkon říkat nebudu.
V pondělí uvidíme,
jestli vůbec je tu možnost,
jestli jestli to má nějaký řešení,
potřeba tam řešit cache flow a nějaký DPH
nebo DPHA tak dále.
Takže příští týden snad už to budou
standardně reportovat,
ale už se tam dějou nějaký akce.
Jo skvělý, ale my jsme se minule říkali,
jestli jsem, jestli mě paměť nešálí.
Tady jsou nějaký předdefinovaný 1 5
nějaký super milníky, že se na to podíváš?
Co to jestli to není kravina a podobně?
Jo tohle víš to jo.
Tady jsou nějaký.
Nepodívala jsem se, zapomněla jsem na to.
Říkám to zcela otevřeně. Omlouvám se,
Asi nám.
podívám se hned teď, jak odreportuju,
tak to otevřu a podívám se na to.
Úplně v pohodě.
Jenom co to je má nemá smysl změnit,
vymazat, přepsat cokoliv. Super jo.
Jo.
Jo jo jo fakt jsem to fakt jsem to úplně
vypustila.
V pohodě, v pohodě,
jenomže ráno tady svítí 1 pátýho od 1
pátýho co dobrý tak jo.
Hele třeba můžu 24 7 tedy další téma.
Tuto ano.
Ano ano.
Tam prosím tě,
jak jsem psala už vlastně v průběhu týdne.
My jsme tam měli malník do třicátýho 4,
že bude vyklizená vyklizený komplet pet
přesunutej do užic. Ten milník posouváme,
je to cílený to posunutí to vyklizení té
plochy mělo bejt vlastně z důvodu toho,
že Lucka potřebovala prosu projekt
vlastně místo na příjem VPO.
Ten ta plocha už je vyklizená,
tam to místo je a není aktuálně potřeba.
Pokračovat v tom vyklízení.
To znamená vlastně šetříme tady nějaký
náklady za za transporty? To znamená,
probíhá,
máme tam teďko nějak na vytížení dopravy
mezi chráštěnama a mezi úžicema?
Takže postupně nakládáme,
postupně odvážíme.
Je tam dohoda jak s Davidem huberem,
tak IS vítkem,
že si prostě dáme vidět třeba za 2 za 3
týdny. Řekneme si, jak jsme na tom a.
Buď prostě přivezeme nepřevezem jo,
případně pokud bych hráče nepotřebovali,
tak řeknou,
krleš mi prostě objednáme objednáme
dopravy a převezen.
Jo a teď tam ta potřeba není.
Číst.
Chápu chápu.
To vyklidit hned.
Jasně, bez dopadu dobře.
Píšu si tady dám poznámku.
Jo, určitě je to bez opadu.
Na projekt je to řízená řízený jako
zpoždění.
Nebo řízenej posun milenku,
tak bych to asi nazvala kvůli zpoždění.
Jo.
Jasně posunul.
Dobrý.
Tak.
Fajn.
A jediný, co se tam bude řešit,
tak je vlastně nebo i jako velký téma.
Tak je právě ten ten kros a na to je
schůzka příští týden.
Ve středu odpoledne.
Provizorní řešení budete on chrvizorní
řešení.
Jo, to je vončo? To je přesně tak,
to je vončo to je schůzka vlastně a hodně
Dobře.
toho rizika, který tam mám popsané.
Jo TDDD to znamená budete se s nimi bavit
a pro vás je o nějakém řešení stihneme
navýšit, co s tím, jo?
Petr backwitch.
Je to tak.
Jako aktuální už máme nějaký,
jak bych to řekla.
Ne symptomy, ale nějaká predikce,
že to zpoždění prostě bude,
takže budeme rovnou vymyslet to náhradní
řešení.
Fyzik.
Vlaštovky.
No drony.
Zkušenost dopravami jo tak.
Napíšu a teďka,
když půjdu jenom sem promiň kliknu,
takhle sem.
Tak hele to bylo znamená to toto si
posílám na jednatřicátýho 5 jo ten pad
tedy 26.
Ano, ale nedával bych to tam nevím úplně,
jestli to tam dát jako milník.
Já to tam prostě že nejdýl k tomuhle.
Datum to zase zrevidujeme. Jo,
že nejdýl do tohohle data countíkem jsem
domluvená za za 2 až 3 týdny,
že si jako napíšeme,
jestli hele jako všechno pořád OK
přesouváme postupně dál,
případně normálně v budchetu máme jako
peníze na ty převozy schválený,
ale přijde nám to prostě zbytečný
plýtvání.
Tak jsme to nějak s Tomem jako zhodnotili.
Já to chápu, ale já to napíšu takhle,
jo nějak jako sympaticky.
Případně.
Jakoby další super review něco takového.
Jinými slovy, může se stát,
že se to bude dít až na konci června,
když si rozhodneme, že to tak bude OK.
Jo.
To jo.
Není tlak, není tlak, napíšu takhle nějak.
Já o tom upravím,
No.
aby to bylo trošku lidsky chápu, chápu.
Rozumím ti není tlak na nebo není potřeba
mít tu plochu vyklizenou.
Je to čistě nějaký takový logický? Prostě.
Třeba.
Řešení.
Jasně, jasně.
Dobře,
tak tady to asi bude jako akceptovaný v
pohodě, tak jo jinak tady asi to je čistý,
tady nic nebylo, gole už to probíhá.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
teď tam řešíme nějakej nákup.
Tiskáren s pikem to tam řešíme teďkon.
Jo.
A už jsem to nikam nepsala,
je potřeba dodat ty konce nejdřív 14 a
zbytek vlastně těch dalších 14 až pak
později.
Tak to je teďkon takový aktuální téma.
To je asi všechno.
No, já jsem teďka právě viděl,
že jsi posílal čerstvé nějaký 4 miliony a
drobný naschválení, že jo něco.
Jo jo jo jo jo.
Tam bylo.
Takže jenom ještě napíšu nákup čeho,
prosím tě nemám.
Poznámka pro knihovníka nákup čeho.
No.
Nebo.
Nákup tiskáren v pickem ale.
To co jsem poslala, to je celý projekt.
To není jenom jakoby to nejsou jenom
tiskárny.
Aha.
OK, takže schvalujeme zpětně nebo?
Jo schvalujeme zpětně.
A.
To je v pohodě.
Není to úplně v pohodě,
ale viděl tam nějaké změny,
takže takže to posílám až teď.
Jo, budou tam zase nějaké úspory,
které původně jsme tam počítat s
Dobře.
nákladama, tak.
Takže posláno na.
Schválení jo konzoli.
Základy projektu řekněme projektu tak tu
low.
Ano ano ano náklady projektu.
Projektu a myslím, že to míra schválně,
která 1 do budou jo?
To je kůže, je to přeschválený.
Míra už to má předjednaný,
je to předchválený jeho připomínky.
Super.
Jsou tam za zaimplementovaný.
Nikol zohlednit takhle?
Jo.
Ano ano, byl jsem s tím v klidu,
není to určitě dobře, není to jako OK.
Dopadlo.
Ale je to už jako mílo schválený.
Jo tak asi to je nějaký jenom data,
že jo štembot shop.
Dobře.
Tak jo tak super,
tak asi tady všechno děkuji terko.
Taky díky.
Budeme na Michala bajku,
destrukce technologií a matroš.
Ondtrack.
Jo jo tak co se týče restrukce nebo
tohodle projektu jako takovýho,
tak tam probíhá teď připomínkování
smlouvy se superxem,
což je ten nějaký aukční portál s Německa,
se kterým chceme spolupracovat.
Máme od nich nějaké všeobecně obchodní
podmínky?
Pročítáme to spolu s prokurmentem,
abychom tam na něčem nenaletěli?
Každopádně říkáme,
že do té aukce chceme jít se seznamem
strojů k odprodeji,
ten už je připravený dál.
Tam chceme dát obalovej materiál.
Na ty nahazuje ten seznam,
zatím tam nějaký položky máme,
ale ještě si myslím,
že tam není úplně všechno.
Co se týče inotechu,
tak tam nově říkáme oproti minulému
tejdnu,
že nechceme do tý aukce dávat věci,
který původně i lo tech označil jako k
vyřazení k vyhození, prý to nedává smysl,
protože jako bylo by s tím víc práce s
nafocením,
než kolik bychom z toho dostali.
Čili dáváme tam jenom ty položky,
který oni připraví, mají termín do zítra.
Do toho seznamu,
že chtějí skutečně dát do aukce pak zbyde
x nějakých položek palet.
To my mají taky do zítra vyčíslit,
který si budou chtít ponechat,
protože z nich stále staví nějaký
dopravníky, ať už tady v Čechách,
tak na Slovensku a bude velká otázka,
kam s tím, jestli to nechat tam,
kde to současně je?
Něco je v chráštěnech něco je ve zdibech
převážná většina. Co vím, tak ve zdibech.
Ale za mě to nejspíš bude muset ve
skladech zůstat,
protože jsem zjišťoval možnosti,
jestli to dokážeme dát na pobočkovou síť
někam do poboček nedokážeme,
není tam vůbec žádné místo. To místo,
které tam bylo, tak se využilo,
když se v uvozovkách likvidovalo LCZ ko
nebo nějakým způsobem přeformovávalo,
takže tam nedokážeme najít místo,
bude prostě otázka, co s tím?
Za sebe riziko,
pokud tohle to za mě jako ještě zatím
A.
není riziko, hledáme ty možnosti.
Na 2 stranu už teďka to v tom skladu máme
tak,
že z toho pohledu to nepovažuju za riziko,
ale co považuju za riziko je to,
co všechno nedokážeme s ohledem na tenhle
projekt tak prodat v tý aukci to znamená
nějakej návrh, co mám říkáme obecně,
že do 1 8 chceme ten sklad vyčistit od
tohohle v uvozovkách bordelu,
tak můj návrh 1 7 si říct,
že tohle jsme v aukci neprodali.
A pojďme říct, že to jdeme vyhodit,
když jiného kupce nedokážeme najít.
Takže zhruba takto k tomu.
Jo.
Takže 1, takže jestli má měsíc,
máte vlastně vavříček?
3 gólem.
Na to, abychom to potom dokázali vyhodit.
Jo,
protože to taky nebude úplně tak
jednoduché.
Ne že bychom to nedokázali asi nechat
odvést ale malinko tam zas narážíme na
nějakou administrativu,
protože ty jednotlivé položky někde máme
tady v evidenci a musíme se s tím umět
vypořádat administrativně.
Takže z toho z toho chápu, co říkáš,
že se může pravděpodobně stát,
že tam něco jako prostě zůstane na těch
skladech, nebo.
Určitě jo, nemáme zkušenost, nevíme,
jak ta aukce bude úspěšná.
Sice ten aukční portál říká,
že dovedou prodat všechno na 2.
Stranu přiznávají,
že spousta věcí prostě prodejných být
nemusí.
OK,
takže potom ve finále jako taková 2
iterace bude co zbyde třeba v tý aukce
nebo co nepůjde na odbyt?
Tak se asi toho 1 7 řekneme,
co s tím jako definitivně.
Jo jo to si projdu s mírou,
on už teďka jako má tendence,
k tomu prostě se toho rychle zbavit,
hlavně vyčistit ten sklad to znamená
Právě.
vyhodit to,
ale ty ztráty v některých případech jsou
relativně vysoký finančně.
No pak jde o to, že jo,
případně ta plocha se využije,
jestli to je cennější než ty ztráty.
Nevím, no, přemejšlím na vás OK?
Jasný.
A ještě ještě jsme dneska dali schůzku
ohledně balení, respektive nebalení.
Byla tam teda i natka,
tak se s tebou asi spojí.
Nebudu se spojila.
Ten spotřebák jako takový dýmka kyselová
a víra malá ještě mají údajně provést
nějakej audit, obalový audit,
nebo tak nějak se to jmenuje David přesně
audit.
Obal nevím.
A já jsem teda řekl tým,
co já jsem teda na tý jestli mi nebylo
dobrý. Se jich teda zeptat,
kdy to jako chtěj udělat,
protože je možný. Neříkám,
že to to ale je možný,
že taky z nich vypadne ještě něco,
že zjistili,
že to něco něco a pravděpodobně taky se s
tím bude muset něco odhodit a podobně.
Takže je možný,
že ještě o nich přijde nějakej stůl,
tak jenom tady.
Ta informace, předávám informaci.
Jo jo mluvili jsme o tom snad i říkala mi
to, děkuju. Vím o tom auditu vím,
že má probíhat třeba 1 za 4 roky nebo
něco takovýho prostě nějaká taková jako
větší iterace. Každopádně, jak jsem říkal,
už minule mi s tím superxem chceme
podepsat smlouvu jakoby rámcovou na
nějakej rok, zhruba s tím,
že se potom dá dodatkem nebo nějakou
novou smlouvou zase prodloužit ta
spolupráce a chceme,
abychom mohli jako skoro kdykoliv udělat
nějakou hromádku více věcí třeba toho
obalového materiálu.
A zkusit to přesně jako v aukci zase
prodat,
ale asi bych nečekal teďka s nějakým
auditem na to, co všechno chceme dát.
Už teď do tý aukce a jakmile bude
podepsaná smlouva a jakmile budeme mít
definovaný ty aktuální seznamy těch věcí,
co chceme do aukce dát,
tak tu aukci spustit,
ať prostě do toho 1 7 dokážeme co nejvíc
prodat.
Samozřejmě samozřejmě, ať to běží.
Předpálí pod kotlem dobrý,
tak to je asi takhle, to je asi všechno.
Skvělý, děkuju.
Packy.
Tak a tady si budu muset přepsat.
Samozřejmě na Lucku,
že jo ten výtlak s 310000 autoškoly už
dobře píšeme na Lucku.
No už je to asi čtvrtej status,
co prezentuji já, tak už by to chtělo.
Pardon.
To je panečku dobrý, tak prosím tě,
já jsem to tady překliknul tebe,
tak vlastně ti to spadlo.
Spadla jsi vlastně v pořadí trošku níž,
takže ještě chvilku počkej jo ještě slovo
teda.
Michalovi r áčku a reversní logistika,
tak rmáčko 1.
Pane máčku 1 já si to tady otevřu.
Co tady to?
Web.
Se teďka jako v tom uplynulym týdnu stalo
tak je,
že do toho už jako existujícího layoutu
procesáci zakreslili.
Ty jako speciální požadavky na na na
elektřinu a.
Datové zásuvky,
jelikož na některých pracovištích bude o
těch zásuvek jako více a on další Šimáček
potřeboval vědět, které to budou,
kolik jich bude a podobně.
Stejně tak točený vzduch,
protože nám na všech pracovištích ho
nepotřebujeme. To znamená, bude jenom tam,
kde je skutečně potřeba. Jo,
takže tohleto tohleto máme připravený
jediný, co nám tam zatím ještě chybí,
tak jsou tak je vyznačení kamer,
abychom to mohli.
Radku vibrigantovi předat tam mám
přislíbeno,
že to dneska zítra bude hotové to dělají
přímo naši provozáci ze zdi pass chrášťan.
Dík.
Pak tady byla ta hr část,
tak tam jsou ty ty rozhovory s těmi
zaměstnanci už dokončeny,
už se tam řeší jenom nějací jako
problémový nicméně.
A ten 1 ten 1.
Ale ten 1.
To to bude asi jako běh na dlouhou trať,
protože tam se to řeší jako skrz legala
jako asi bude to,
ale já jsem to upřímně jako poslal do
vlády tenhle člověk jako zůstane v krejch.
Buď se ale jako zbavíme do té doby nebo
sám odejde a nebo mu tam najdeme nějaké
jako uplatnění.
A další důležité,
co se týče vůbec jako nastavení toho
Jasně.
zpětného toku,
tak procesáci z doprav už už si to prošli.
A vlastně,
co se týče jako zpětného toku z alzaboxu
AZ poboček.
Tak tam v tom nastavení problém nevidí.
Jenom potřebujou dostat nějakou jako ten
ten noltice o tom, že?
Se stěhujeme aspoň nějakou čtrnáctidenním
předstihem,
protože ty změny v tom nastavení těch
svozů budou obsáhlejší.
Nicméně jako 2 otazníčky,
které tam teďka máme,
tak je nastavení zpětných adres u
balíkářů. To znamená,
když s námi odesíláme.
Jo jo,
když chráš tohle odesílám zákazníkovi
Jo.
objednávku na adresu dopravce a on si ji
nevyzvedne,
tak se nám dneska vrací zpátky do krášan.
No, otázka je,
jestli jako všichni dopravci mají možnost
změnit tu zpětnou adresu a případně kolik
to bude stát? Jo,
tady teďka vlastně počkám.
Od toma mám dostat nějaký jako odhadovaný
objem polik tady těchhle těch balíčků se
nám měsíčně do chrášťan vrací.
Abychom, případně si spočítali,
kolik to bude stát a jestli se třeba
nevyplatí udělat tolik toho pracoviště v
chrášťanech,
které tam pracuje a nebo je potřeba něco
lépe jako vědět znát nebo posunout dál,
nebo nějaký další termín, čeho chytnete?
Hele, no teďka to má na sobě.
Adam kysilka,
komerční specialista do práv,
který má říct jako.
Cenu cenu za tu zpětnou adresu.
Pokud bychom ji chtěli jo,
tomu se to dneska zadával.
Měl by to mít do zítra hotový.
Potom si to můžeme jako propočístko.
Jak to bude stát při těch webemech,
které máme.
AA pak pak to jako projdu zinkem,
abychom se rozhodli,
jestli to má zůstat v krášťanech,
nebo jestli to budeme,
jestli to budeme i akceptovat.
A do kdy jak?
Chceš prostě vědět,
jak to bude a případně říct?
Hele jdi na se do kdy?
Hele za mě do konce května úplně jako
dostačující,
protože tam pak jako potřebujeme 14 dnů
nastavení, a to pořád jako máme buffe,
takže tady klidně jako.
Sirijeme čas.
Potom míříš jako jo, že do pokud je černá.
Čas.
Vlastně ten 14 dní je konec května a pak
14 dní na stavební teprka.
Černá tak.
A máte ještě půlku měsíce a pak dáte góly.
Přesně no tak jako pokud jako do konce
května rozhodneme, jestli ten zpětný. To,
co těch balíkářů bude, tak a nebo tak,
tak jsme schopni pořád jako za měsíc se v
Tohle řešení do jednatřicátého 5 jo,
takže vlastně bych tohle očekával potom v
pohodě zařídit.
těch milnicích 3 týden, že tam flikneš?
Jo.
Takže pokud,
který tady napíšu takhle jenom jo,
tak co to 2 možnost zavedení DPD svodu?
DPD tak tam je potom DPD.
Vysvětlím,
dneska posíláme reklamace do servisu z
chrášťan DPD pokud tam ten daný servis
nemá zařízený nějaký jako samos problém
je v tom, že.
DPD se s tím dneska.
Nerzni podle posledních informací,
co mám a muselo by tam dojíždět čistě
kvůli těmdle těm reklamacím to znamená
úplně stejný case.
Adam kyselka momentálně zjišťuje možnosti,
kolik by to stálo tenhle náklad by
stoprocentně šel za ja r ma to znamená.
Tady bychom tady bychom jako museli
počítat s nějakým vícenákladem jo,
Jo myslíš jako?
přesně tak tam jako denní svoz balíků ze
zdi,
protože v opačném případě bychom to mohli
zase jako crossova dokrášť dám to, DP.
Jezdí,
ale zase bychom prodlužovali těmi
reklamační proces.
Vlastně aktuální crossina přijímají závoz
odvoz.
Přesně tak,
a ten ten termín vlastně úplně stejnej
ten případ jo?
A pak 14 impletaci AA tak dále,
abyste měli prostě do 1 7 nebo do půlky
června, jo bude to stejný.
Jo.
Ať je to ať je to nastavený tak nebo tak,
ale ať to jako máme rozhodnutý aby se to
nastavil ať tam od 1.
Světový přijde a teď nebudeme mít kam
poslat ten balík,
protože tam to DPD nebude třeba.
Tak a co dál tam?
Směrem projít, co dál, co dál?
Tady se možná budu potom jako duplikovat
IS reverskou.
Nicméně na příští týden je naplánováno
setkání s dodavateli internetu.
Tam bude pravděpodobně mirico.
A elektřiny tohle zaštiťuje Honza Šimáček
a Martin čech.
Bude se to řešit společně s reverskou.
Jediný,
co tady ještě potřebujeme a mám
přislíbeno odvítka, že nám dodá,
tak je dokončení layoutu pro ty adminy,
které budou, kteří budou.
V tom nadzemním podlahy společně s
remáčkem mám to ještě nemáme.
Dodat jo jo.
Jo, to víte.
Dneska jsem s ním o tom mluvil.
Ve své podstatě,
to je jenom jako zakreslení nějakých 8 10
stolů do tohoyoutu KDVG.
Takže není to nic jako extra náročného.
Jenom to potřebujeme proto,
aby to jako shimi mohl ukázat tomu
dodavateli.
Tak no a na tohle to samozřejmě bude
navazovat požadavek na ty dodavatele,
aby nám dodali nějakou,
dodali nějakou cenovku a my si to náš
Kolik dat kolik dát?
časum, ale já beru,
že tohle to mi jako řeknou,
protože já s tímhle tím jako já mám
zkušenost a já beru,
že po tom setkání mi to řekne jako Martin
s Honzou šimáčkem, že hele ten.
A to se nám jako vyjádří do tehdy a do
tehdy.
Se nám jako vyjádří do tehdy a do tehdy.
14 dní, 14 dní měl.
Jeho zkušenosti na chrám černé 14 dní
byla OK,
protože se budou podívat ještě jako
doptávat. Potom ještě se něco,
i když ten náplavce budou,
tak se ještě možná doptávat,
respektive něco ti můžou poslat tady na
tu US,
než to je píčovina a budete se jako ještě
obracet. Takže počkejte si otočíš 14 dní,
asi jich máš víc ne že jo, máš jich víc,
nebo jenom ty 2 elektriku a.
Tolik kolik jich tam pozval Honza Šimáček
na elektriku na data.
Tady tam měl být myslím jenom miricom.
Jo jo dobře no.
No tak takhle nějak no,
že prostě tohle tohle a oni ti řeknou,
oni ti pravděpodobně řeknou i termín,
kdy budu moci začít.
To ti řeknu, jo.
Sobotou šej to už ví ne,
no takže se ještě dozvíš.
Já jsem vlastně jako moje zadání jako
vůči Honzovi a Martinovi bylo to,
že prostě 1 7 to musí být ready,
kde mě jako ubezpečili,
že to jako stihneme.
To jako máš?
2 měsíce jo, pokud ti to nevadí,
že to bylo třeba ještě od vás červnu,
tak jsi v pohodě nevadí dobře.
Tak to pak je vyřeším, jo.
A potom.
My to schválně rozpočtu na na míru na
míru? Jo,
tak tam počítač ještě jako hodně otázek
na to.
Jo že ho to zajímá jo, respektive takhle,
my ti pomůžu mi z inkem.
My máme každých 14 dní s mírou.
Ty pondělní schůzky ohledně toho programu
jo teďka vlastně tam byla a byla tam
vlastně říct o razítko ohledně navýšení
kapacity přímo nějakých prostě hrozbě
míra tam něco a vlastně řekl,
tak kdo to chcete? DDA vlastně jako úplně,
nebo úplně jinak, takže vlastně?
Za 14 dní vol za 14 dní pondělí je další
další status, takže by se to stihnul.
Tak ti dám pozor a ty vlastně máš šanci
si to tam jako odprezentovat a dozví se
hned od míry za zatepla.
Jak to prostě odvidí a případně se ještě
dobrou. A to si ale upřímně myslím,
že nespíme, protože jestli říkáš,
S.
že to jako trvá 14 dnů,
než dostaneme cenovku.
Třeba všichni už jako řekne něco za ty.
Tomáš, já nevím, jo, nabízím. Hele,
bylo to teďka dvacátýho sedmýho 11.
Jedenáctýho května je další informace,
že tam je další.
Tam bys mohl přijít pan kaýho, jo,
tak by to jo urgentní hořelo,
tak zkusíme se dohodnout s mírou.
Vybírat asi přejet ro to trošku jako ř
jednodušit.
On nechce takový ty individuální,
prostě schvalovačky.
On chce prostě ty skupinový,
aby ty informace se neztrácely a aby si
to lidi dozvěděli, že co.
Se.
Stalo jo,
takže jedenáctýho je nejvyšší termín.
Informace pro tebe,
že bys mohl přijít na schvalovačku? OK,
OK.
jo, tak.
Proč to platí vlastně pro Německu? Jo?
No a pak tady mám v dalších krocích jenom
ty dopravy,
o kterých jsme teďka se bavili,
protože teďka asi bude živé téma adam
adam.
Odpovědět.
Ky pak to začneme začínat porovnávat.
Hele tady asi to jde sníh a asi to nějak
běží. Rizika tady nějaký máš teďka, ale.
Hele.
URA, ne URM mám,
mám nějak riziko u reversky,
AK tomu se dostanu.
Jsem na to advoká jo a rizika.
Rizika nejsou jo no a byla ta škola proto,
aby to toho 1 sebíjí? Jo jo.
Respektive ty rizika,
které jsme si tady jako pojmenovali,
tak už.
Už jsme si je jako pominuli,
byl to ten výtah,
byl to ta kolaudace a tam jsme si to
všechno tak nějak jako.
A mimochodem ten výtah jak jste se bavili,
to odpisování je proběhne nějak to před
dalistikou.
Nebo jak to?
Jo, ale vlastně já beru,
že v minulém jinak jako dal informaci,
že to půjde logistice.
To znamená teďka akorát budeme muset se
zincem AS Davidem petrášem domluvit.
Jak se to udělá účetně,
jak to má bejt správně?
No aby aby se to jako fakt stalo. No.
Třeba pepno.
Dobře pravděpodobně ale reverská.
Něco je shodnýho něco shodnýho ale budu.
Budu jako stručnější informace
nedublikoval.
Co se týče těch doprav úplně stejná
písnička, jo,
tady to mám vlastně jako zduplikovaný,
primárně ty nevyzvednuté objednávky se
týkají jako raversky,
protože tam se maj zpracovávat.
Co se týče těch svozů DBE,
tak vlastně taky, protože.
Reverská následně bude mít na starost by
to odesílání reklamací do servisu mezi be.
K tomu navážu informací,
kterou jsem tady ještě nedal.
Protože čerstvá dozvěděl jsem se,
že velkou zpracování velké bílé bez
hýbech už je jako logistikou
odsouhlasenou přesouváme do kůžic,
což je pro tenhle projekt dobrá zpráva,
protože nám vznikne dostatek prostoru pro.
To pro to odesílání těch reklamací do
toho do těch servisů a manipulace
raversky obecně.
Je to vlastně jako prostor,
kde dneska tam,
kde se zpracovává velká bílá,
tak tam jsou vlastně gate a pro tohle to,
co tam potřebujeme,
je to vlastně ideální prostor. To znamená,
aby došlo tam k dohodě mezi mezi vastilem
mírou o 5 a předpokládám i Ondrou danešem.
Máme to potvrzený od inka.
Jediné co tak se tam bude řešit zaškolení
lidí,
protože ty lidi mají být pod logistikou,
ale já beru tohle to,
že si řeší jako bokem.
Martin miňošský z logistikou a jde to
jako mimo tenhle ten projekt.
Zde.
Domluvili se tam na termínu,
že by to mělo být jako k 1. 6 přesunutý.
Pro mě je to pro mě to tedy znamená,
že jako 1 7 tam máme prostor,
aby jsme se tam nasáčkovali s tou.
Když říkáš, že mě tak musíš.
Třídit normálně spíš.
Myslím třídit 0 jo jo.
Dobře dobře, tak.
Tady člověče, ale.
Ještě no jasně,
ale co se týče té infrastruktury,
tak tady je to trošičku složitější. Tady,
jak jsem říkal, čekám nabídka,
až mi až mi dodá ten to pracoviště pro ty
admi.
Zároveň jsme se s Hynkem dohodli,
že ty počty zásuvek na elektřinu a data.
Si Martin čech s Honzou šimáčkem doplní
sami.
Já jsem se s nima o tom bavil,
oni s tím jako nemaj problém,
protože to nebude 0 jako specifické
pracoviště.
Jediný co já zítra budu v krášťané,
zítra si tam nafotím jak ty stoly vlastně
vypadá je kolik tam zásuvek je a tak dále
a ať to máme jako čerstvý.
AAA vlastně to klukům takhle takhle
předám, nebudeme jim to tam zakrysl,
tak jako jsme to udělali u adamačka.
Co se týká, toho bere q,
tady jsem poprosil toma.
Já nevím jestli tady je.
No pardon, tome.
Je tady.
Tak jestli jestli dáš shrnutí jak jsme na
tom s tím breq pros to a já říkám za prvé.
Jo jo.
Co se týče,
co se týče těch nějakých potenciálních IT
zásahů, tak vlastně po tom,
co jsme měli pár dnů zpátky nějakou
diskuzi s Honzou kozákem, tak.
Jsme na na základě nějakých jako nějaké
diskuze nějakého doporučení otestovali,
jak se nám v třídírně chová naskloňování,
respektive jak se chová distribuce.
Víceméně, když to řeknu, tak šalamounsky,
tak funguje, ale jenom tak napůl, takže.
Tam jsme došli k tomu,
že je potřeba tam ještě dozaložit nějakou
jako speciálně nastavenou sekci,
aby se všechno tvořilo správně,
protože teď aut teď aktuálně jakoby jsme
schopni ji generovat,
ale musí se to dělat manuálně.
Je to strašně nepraktické,
takže tam na to máme,
respektive Ondra Kreml na to má sepsaný
nějaký krátký log.
To já beru relativně jako formalitu.
Potom s tím přímo či nepřímo souvisí
nějaké to naše párování pro převozy.
Protože tím, že my to budeme naskloňovat.
V týdně,
tak my to potřebujem potom dostat i
systémově a mít nějaký jako track record
na ostatní sklady.
Tak mám sepsáno zadání už.
Už jako ve finální formě.
Které bych chtěl,
pokud teda se v následujících.
60 minutách ještě nezmění něco zásadního
zítra představovat na IT ten Honza kozák
jako víceméně nějakým způsobem už o tom
jako ví,
ale ještě jsme to jako nevykopávali ofiko.
Vždycky v.
V případě nouze, kdyby nám IT řeklo,
že protože jsem slyšel takové jako
vlaštovky,
že to jest kapacitně teďka možná trošku
jako napjatější tak, aby nám řekli,
že na nás nebudou mít do konce toho
června na tohle čas,
tak teoreticky by to bylo schopné
fungovat i.
I bez té úpravy využili bysme standardní
proces distribuce.
Ale.
Teď jako v tom řekněme mírném časovém
prsu, jako je nevýhoda ta,
že my to vlastně nemůžeme otestovat
plnohodnotně,
dokud nebudou mít hotový ten ondrův log
na tu na tu na to založení té sekce.
Takže.
Jako primárně jako budejím cílem pokusit
se IT alokovat na to,
aby jsme byli schopni to dělat.
Tedy přes to varování.
Bezpečnosti řečeno prostě bude tam,
jakoby dá se říct o krok méně.
Bude to v rámci jako 1 kroku.
Jak bude to efektivnější?
Každopádně nejsme schopni to dělat možná
zatím teoreticky říkám i jinak,
akorát to nejsme schopni ještě otestovat.
A zároveň jsme měli i nějakou diskuzi s
Honzou s Honzou s Tomášem houdou ohledně
těch toků.
Které se nějakým způsobem dotýkají RMA.
Tam jsme si řekli, že?
Pokud by tam,
respektive byl tam od rocker se mnou a
předávali jsme si jenom nějaké jako
důležité věci,
které je potřeba jako nějakým způsobem
nastavit.
A na co nezapomenout a jsme domluveni IS
Tomem,
že kdyby ještě přišel na něco zásadního,
to by bylo potřeba tam od IT.
Tak ještě nám dát vědět. Každopádně,
když bych to shrnul jinými slovy,
tak vlastně.
Když by bylo nejhůř,
budeme schopni teoreticky to dělat bez IT,
ale ne, ještě bych na to nespoléhal.
Tolik jako asi za to.
Nějaký stránky debližtem.
Za.
Teda.
No tak já asi si myslím,
že primárně se dozvím podle zpětné vazby,
kterou dostanu strádáno na tom sinkus IT.
OK termín známý.
Pokud bysme šli tou jednodušší cestou v
tom smyslu, že?
Využijeme ten proces distribuce.
Tak.
Sekce to asi jako je otázka příštího
týdne.
Pokud to otestujeme a bude to fungovat,
tak víceméně.
Nemáme už pak řešit,
pokud bysme šli tou cestou,
že budeme potřebovat dělat tady ten vývoj,
tak vůbec si netroufnu odhadnout,
jak dlouho to bude trvat.
Ale jako není to úplně otázka.
1 dne si myslím, takže fakt záleží,
co řekne to IT zítra.
Dobře.
A píšu jsem nutné doplnit ten termín jo
nutno doplnit termín co se dozvíš.
Jo jo jo.
Děkujeme.
Ta dáme z toho kamero systému.
Jinak tady není,
já jsem to tady chtěl stáhnout.
Přesně.
Já to s ním proberu. Nicméně tak,
jak jsme si řekli,
že elektřinu data si zajistíš jimi a
Martin čech.
Tak vlastně nám tady chybí jako někdo,
kdo nám Michael zakreslí.
Má zakaset znamená, že vám řekne tohleto,
ale má to smysl. Takový je tu logiku,
aby aby řekl,
chci mít tu kameru tady tady a tady,
protože tady chci.
Viděl z nějakého důvodu.
A teď jako nevim, kdo by to měl bejt jo,
protože ono to jako pak neudělá.
A vítám.
On pak to pak jako validuje,
jestli je to OK.
Ale já to proberu z inka mi doporučí
nějaké jméno na kolo se obrátím se tam.
Kazeta.
Miku, prosím tě napadá tě někdo miku,
ty kamery tohle?
Asi takhle na 1 dobrou ne?
Ale třeba to bude jako Vasil,
ale já nevím jo,
protože vlastně nakonec a priverzní
logistiku tam nemá. Takže on jako.
AK adresu.
Tam chrašené bude,
jsou chrášané hnusný logistiku.
A vezmeme tuším.
To už to už jako je nějaký pátek.
Vůbec netuším a nemáčko jsme si dělali
zase jako sami.
Nějakej můžu to tam mít.
Procesák za reversku je tón že jo,
ale to mi je procesák za reversku teďka
měsíc a.
Řešili jsme to.
Ale obecně obecně reversku chraštelně,
jestli ještě dělal provoz sám za sebe.
Myslím,
že s Patrikem a devčíkem a davem bečičkou.
Přesně tak, teď jsem.
Teď jsem to chtěl říct,
že jsme si to stavili sám.
A myslím, že já ani 1 už tady ale není.
Na jehočička tady je ještě.
Jo a mohlo by pomoct.
Tak já myslím, že určitě.
David bečička ano,
jak se jmenuje David jo jo jo.
Ano David beckých.
Tak výborně. Já měl za to,
že už tady není, tak děkuji.
Takže sčičkou na max tam člověka teďka
super a pak je tady to bere q tady
vlastně to shrnulo to a pak tady mám ty
dopravy jo jakože co se stane když.
Se nestane nic,
tak to může být mít dopad na golive ve
smyslu toho,
že část těch procesů dose budeme muset
nechat rád, což.
Předpokládám, nechceme.
To znamená tohleto jako vnímám jako
riziko, ale zároveň zároveň moc nevíme.
Řešíme.
Takhle dala by to asi naprd.
No ale tak jako.
Třeba s tímto.
Zjistíme,
že ekonomicky je to nejlepší varianta,
protože třeba.
Jo.
Nevím hele rekvetico jo ono to souvisí s
doprava s tím pádem kysilkou jo a tak dál,
DPDA tak dále jo paní kouknu ještě rychle
sem jenom promiň tak tady máme revers
crat RD.
Tak mělo být návrh na straně nových tras.
Tereza zůstává zpětně na to dvacátýho
čtvrtýho, to je 5 dní zpátky co jo?
No tak to je to,
o čem jsem vlastně mluvil? Teď je otázka,
jestli jestli to tady díky těmhletěm
dvoum háčkům,
jako máme pusu do konce května.
Třeba nebo a nebo si říct je,
je to hotový, aby vstali tady další.
Díky za mě bych to jako jenom posunul
vole ať to jako nehledá.
Dřív byl připraven návrh nastavení,
abych teda připraven návrh je připraven,
nebo?
Kdy?
Bude připraven,
ale připraven je ale součástí toho je,
že musíme vyřešit to. DPDA ty balíká,
že jo.
Takže tak,
jak jsem tam vlastně říkal ten konec?
Května no.
OKA je.
Nějak připravenej,
ale úplně ještě potřeba ho trošku dopíct.
Jo ABRQ.
Vede k vaječku?
13 to 4 hele tome máš ty zítra třeba to 4
to bude on.
OK.
Tam asi to zítra aktualizujeme po té
diskuzi SITN třeba to.
Vím o tom.
No napište prosím tě a projdu to kdyžtak
dalo.
Teda,
když přesně to a potom tady prosím tě,
ty třicátýho 4 rozpočet toho systému 34.
A tady prosímtě,
to je to samé ne zcela to je 1 kdo z něj
najít?
To je to stejný to.
Je to stejný.
Já myslím že dupliku ano.
Pohyb.
Dobrý, tak jo, tak vás už všechno děkuji.
Tak půjdeme dál, tedy Martin, prosím tě,
jde po Plzeň 1.
Kontrac.
Opravdu ontra?
Začal on trek já jsem tady to tvoje
zadání dnešní porady pochopila trošku
jinak, takže já mám jenom rizika.
V pohodě, v pohodě nevadí.
A co se týká rizik na depopozeň,
tak je smlouva ještě není podepsána.
I když už máme jakoby ujednání,
že jsme se shodli na to na té smlouvě a
mají podepsat jakoby tenhle týden.
A každopádně to ohrožuje.
Ty hlášky na úhrady goly HPPA kvůli
odpadám.
Ale ondro o tom ví a musíme jenom čekat,
no nic jiného proto, že nám můžeme udělat.
Jo tam jsou nějaký hr nějaký věci k
diskuzi? Prej i se mi se nelíbí.
Ano ano ano přesně.
Protože padněme do kategorizace práce,
který asi.
Hele a.
Ano to není úplně chtěný.
Ne není.
Tak ideálně dvojka.
Hele a tady prosím tě,
když se to jako nestíhá nebo nestihne,
20.
tak co to znamená vlastně?
To znamená to,
že bysme mohli tam ty lidi načerno?
No to jo to znamená.
Takhle no jasně, taková ta lidská rovina,
ale takový to jako pohyb toho projektu to
spuštění.
Tak jestli Ondra zobere na sebe riziko
jakož hlavní vedoucí prohozákou,
tak se to spustí a neohrozí to spuštění
projektu. Jestli Honza Ondra řekne,
že tak do toho nejde,
tak se to prostě posune. No.
Doposunulo spuštění jo píšu rob.
Ten jako.
Ale ondré říká, že potřebuje 14 dní,
takže jak se to tenhle?
Jak se to dneska zejtra podepíše,
tak se to stihne tam nahlásit na tu na ty
úřady.
A 14 dní odkdy od včerejška nebo dřív od
14 dní.
Od poslání,
že vlastně jakoby potřebuje na tom teda
14 dní,
jako když to odešleš tak než to dorazí na
ty úřady a všechno,
tak je tam nějaký limit 14 dní.
Jo.
Tak já tady Martina píšu jenom nutné.
Sledovat no nebo prostě.
To jo,
já jsem v kontaktu denně s antonom a
Jo jo.
urguju ho za to.
Tak.
A 2 riziko je.
Ježíš ježišmarja.
Ano, přesně tak,
každý den si úspěšně volám za Martinem
Čechem.
Potřebuju prostě cenovku na miricom.
Abysme si to nechali schválit konzoli.
A dneska jsem se po poradě s honzom
domluvila, že v případě,
že to dneska nebude,
tak mi Honza dal číslo na pana vránu a
zavolám si na miru kam sama.
A zkusím to sníh dostat já.
Super.
Hele a tady no jasně, no hele,
a tady prosím tě ještě 1 věc tady.
Jedenáctýho 5 tady až na jedenáctýho.
Ano.
5.
Ano.
Já jsem to chtěla být původně hotovo do 8
5.
Jo.
A vím, že prostě stále nemáme cenovku.
Tak to Martin naplánoval na start 11 5,
což je týden před testovacím provozem
jako mírikon to stihne,
natahá to jako nebude problém,
ale musejí tam 11 5 nastoupit jo.
To chápu no.
To už bude hodně fakt jako napjatý.
Ano.
Klasika Martinem.
Takovej fakt jako ten čas prožral no no.
Blbý no dobrý den.
Má to měsíc u sebe, takže jako nevím čím,
jako jak jsme to ještě mohli ovlivnit. No.
Tak.
Jo.
Jsme ven.
Locker máme jednodavatele, no to je blbý.
Jo, přesně tak.
Hele OKA, když já teda pojedeme rychle,
marti sem nahoru zašroluju.
Ano ano.
Tohle teda máme tady třicátýho 4 z
minulého týdne.
Toto jo to schválení budovy na podpis
mluvy.
Jo jo jo ano nech to.
Tak máme ten hele, necháme to bejt.
Tak jo.
Personální obsazení wordpan a podobně.
34 co?
Toto podle mě nedopadne,
protože čekáme na dopravy až na pripravě
trasy.
Abysme dokázali říct to okno,
které musí být,
musí být pro otvoreně a máme začali jenom
1. Kolo a nemáme časové okno vratik.
Ale já mluvím s Davidem blahovcem taky
jako naděnej bázi,
jak možná nechte takhle uvidíme. Možná,
že to stihneme.
Dobře,
takhle to nechám a já se a případně si
dejme třeba půl hodinku potom sólo jo a
projděme ty všechny věci tady,
Jasně.
protože tady vlastně jsou dalších 2 4 5
věcí toto jo?
A spuštění a pravděpodobně asi tak teda
nějakým způsobem se to se to šoupne.
Asi ne toto.
To vypadá, že to stihne většinou.
Okej, dobře.
Tak jenom čtvrt jakoby je a já se
případně no vlastně hnedka třicátýho tak
ono je 1 je svátek,
takže bych se v pondělí pozval,
připomněl a řekli bychom si,
jak na tom jseš.
Jo.
OK, jasně můžeme umím.
Jo, počkáme,
jestli si něco vyberbí třeba 1 plánova.
Počkej.
Já nevím, nechci bejt jako to dobroš.
Každopádně je tady 18.
Čas.
5 testování to zůstává zatím.
Ano,
ano směřujeme k tomu a chceme pustit čest.
Trest, testovací rampapu.
Jasný, jasný a teďka co mi,
co mi tady říkáš ITATD termín golan
patnáctýho 6 by asi neměl být ne nějak
dotčen.
Ne neměl, neměl.
Dobře.
I kdybysme testování jakoby testovat se
testování a pustili o týden později,
Jo.
tak stejně ty trasy pustíme a všechno
spustíme. Před 15 6.
Dobře dobře OK, tak jo.
Tím necháme takhle a já půjdu teda dál.
Půjdu teda na to 2 téma a systémy pokrytí
třicí den to lepší téma.
To necháte ho lepší téma z těch 2 promiň.
Já to jenom tady odbouknu se omlouvám tak.
Tak to lepší téma z těch 2 systémů.
Tak představujeme depa teďkon jsme.
Petry.
Já jsem to nechala entrisk včera jsme se
domluvili s dopravami na strategii českou
republiku.
My v této chvíli jedeme na hosín,
udělá 2 pokus, tak snad to dopadne.
Pak bysme to hned spustili další týden,
následně nový bydžo máme v pláně příští
týden na testy.
A pak půjdeme do povně, spustíme Plzeň.
A pak bysme šly do vrativova. My víme,
že vratíme, není ideální.
Je malý, víme,
že potenciálně tam můžeme do budoucna ho
spojit s Přerovem a může tam být naše
nové alzy depo rebars.
Ale co je průser a co nás bude brzdit
bude gem.
Protože gem není schopen,
zatím se mu nepodařilo najít to větší
depo.
Tak my jsme včera tu strategii otočili a
říkáme gamu nové požadavky, aby si našli.
Menší depo na XL současné depo nechali
pre ABAXL dělali někde jinde.
Ale to v tejto kvalitu zadávali.
Ardi možná dneska komunikoval s gemom,
protože jsme se včera odpoledne na tom
domluvili,
takže já jsem ten to spuštění gemu teď
nastavila na poslaný květ poslaný červen.
Ale já to v této chvíli úplně vašku nevím.
A jak moc je to velký? Je problém toto?
Je to velkej problém?
Protože ten gém je pro nás nej
strategickejch a depo ohrožuje to ten.
Projekt co má Tereza s Tomem ohledně
lcúčka a krosování do chrášťa?
Takže my jsme na to s hyňkem tlačili a
hledali jsme cesty,
jak bysme to mohli zakrýt a tohle je ten
výsledek.
Jo,
tohle byl ten návrh vlastně jako jak to z
toho jako aspoň trošku to změnit.
Tak přesně tak,
jak z toho vybruslit a čím dřív prostě
uvolnit ty krosis užít do chrašta.
Hele a chápu do roku 27 to je to znamená
jakoby tohle tohle ten typ toho řešení
toto, jo?
To ano a pak za nás je to všichni jsme se
shodli na tom, že by bylo nejideálnější,
aby se tam spustilo 1 velké depo,
ktoréby obstarávalo o všechny tady ty
činnosti plus ta markét malá návrh,
ještě aby to sloužilo jako prekladiště
nějakých 3 zemí,
takže to je ale už jako troška p kafe no.
To. V.
OK,
takže tohle to jako největší hrozba
riziko řešení tady nějaký jakoby?
Ano.
Je.
Ano.
Tato řešení, jak to říct?
Je jako životaschopný.
Jo je je životaschopný mimo.
Věříme Michal můžu potvrdit to tam se
mnou, když to takhle postavíme,
tak tak to bude žít a bude to dobrý.
Jediný jediný háček,
který tady jakoby vzstal, je,
že my ve chvíli,
kdy uděláme nové XL de pop.
Tak v tu chvíli bude jako velký tlak na
to přepnout ty brněnské direkty z
chrášťánu na line holi mar jo.
A je.
Jo, jo, já s tím počítám.
Jo a pak je otázka jestli tam to zase
nezabije prostorově, že jo.
To budeme pak Zdeňkem vyjednávat,
až budeme vědět, jak to dopadlo,
tak určitě půjdeme za Davidem a budeme
jednat s Hynkem s Davidem.
Jo.
Jak to udělat nej nejlíp prostě.
Direct malinho jo tady píšu,
je to správně hotový.
Počítám s tím.
Jo.
A to je problém, nebo to prostě bude?
Protože dneska já teďka nevím,
kolik těch directových tras z chrášťá do
brna je, řekněme klidně jako 10.
To je teď 1.
Jo ale 11 tak těch 11.
11.
Se jako přepne na linewall,
tím pádem by se mělo jako ulevit zase
jako chrášťan.
Ale jako bude chodit 11,
ale takovou to jako objemné trasy.
Tohleto teďka jsem řekl,
má to dopad do nějakýho harmonogramu
čehokoliv jiného čerta tahleta jako
vlastně jako nový zjištění,
že jo v podstatě jde nebo doplňující
zjištění.
No bude to jako nějaký dopad do
prodloužení nebo do prachů nebo do
kvality, nebo když to má dopadnýho?
Já jsem tím chtěl říct, že se může stát,
že ve chvíli,
kdy se ty direkty přepnou na line holi,
tak tam nemusí být dostatek prostoru na
to systémové.
Třídění.
A bude se třeba to muset udělat tak jako
ve vratimově.
Jestli to říkám marťa správně?
Jo říkáš, ale já si myslím,
když tam na zemi to XL nebude,
tak bysme se tam ale vejít na ten gem.
Potom jsme vám ještě zajít podívat na to.
Dobrý hele ne to je pojmenovaný dopady
teďka do prostoru a.
Ale.
Tak jo.
Takže paní marťas mě přerušil,
jestli chceš pokračovat teda.
A prosím tě, jediné,
co tady zůstává otevřené,
tak je reporting hraje,
protože vývoj storie zpožděný a my
potřebujeme vlastně sledovat,
jak se nám daří na ty účel systémových
dep.
Takže tam tam zůstává tohle riziko a my
tlačíme s vítkem na ajťáky,
aby dovyvinuli ty nutné storky,
které potřebujeme. To jediné,
co můžeme tyto kvůli dělat.
Takže ikdyž prosím tě zeptám se tady teda
ten hostýn už je IT infra nějak jako
zlepšenej.
Ano máme to ověřené z 5 stran,
jinak bysme nejeli?
Tibejžov.
Ibi jo.
OK.
IV račimov pan byl Michal osobně.
To je vlastně.
Dobrá zpráva.
A ten vývoj tady, prosím tě,
je to nějaký kritický bloger, když to,
když vázne a nebude,
nebo bude takovej jako kostrbatý?
Ano je to je to kritickej bloker,
protože my sice jakoby zavedeme systémové
data,
ale nebudeme to do nedokážeme to
vyhodnocovat.
Stavbu.
A nějaký termín tohodle jenom se podívám
sem.
Že nám to.
Už jste si řekli tady?
Já jsem to neřekli, jsme si,
neřekli jsme si.
No.
Tady hele.
Včetně trekingu trasování repotigu zítra.
Tak to nebude zítra.
Hele dobře.
Zase já bych to prošel s tebou salo to
depo a tohle.
OK.
Jo a to tady to obraz se trošku.
OKOK no,
protože tady to systémové DPS prehází
kompletně všechno. Ty milníky,
to se celé posune,
to musíme spolu probrat.
No radši jo radši jo tak vykro osob.
No dobře,
tak já si to vyškrtnu tohle a nebudu tady
posílat dobrý.
Ještě k tomu něco Martin tady asi zatím.
Jo, slovenská část.
Tam je to nejkritičtější,
tam stále nevíme, jak to bude.
My jsme dali návrh market slíbila,
že to projednají na VR ku a že nám dá
vyjadrně za dopravy,
jako to viděj oni a možná že tady ta část
vůbec nebude.
A tím pádem se to posune až do nového do
dalšího roku.
Takže v této chvíli?
To je ohrožení úplně.
No.
Trvat.
No a.
Jasně,
co to znamená jako pro fungování
logistiky nebo tak? Co toto na příští rok?
No prej Filip jako že to znamená,
že že bude slepej jak že bude,
že bude pořád slepej jak jsme slepí,
že mu to bude kazit tu kvalitu,
kterou nebude moc ovlivnit.
No a nějaký jakoby finální rozhodnutí je
s ornou to bude nebo?
No právě na to čekáme za dopravy,
že markét by malá přijít s nějakou
strategii na Slovensko a na základě toho
se určí,
Jo.
jestli tady ten návrh je živej nebo ne,
a nebo jestli mají o ni svůj na nějakej
návrh a podle toho, kde děláme ten na.
Jo.
Váš projekt, ale já to tlačím,
protože to potřebujeme vědět,
když nám to někdo řekne v září, tak.
Pasivně stihneme.
Občas si je.
Jo, takže kamíček je na straně marketing?
Tak ať.
Ano prosím ano,
prosím to přeletu takhle to.
Tak jo.
No ty jo tak to zase nebude,
není dobrá zpráva,
to se zase vrátil zpátky do bodulo dobroš
Martin zítra si spojíme jo na těma
milníkama.
Jo dobře určitě můžem, tak jo, mějte se.
Tak jo, děkuju.
Když mi palce posíně.
Děkujeme.
Tak lucko,
vzal bych prosím tě výtlak a navýšení
příjmů. Manipulačku bych dneska přeskočil.
Někdo bychom nechali, zatím to.
Tak výtlak.
Tak jdem na to.
Tak co se týče výtku,
tak půjdeme podle hexagonu.
My jsme si to tady rozepsali.
Podle těch jednotlivejch bodů toho
hexagonu a vždycky jsme k tomu napsali,
jestli tam vidíme nějaké riziko.
Tak u té aplikace.
Tam jsme se shodli,
že zatím žádný update nemáme.
Další změnu očekáváme někdy v průběhu
června.
Momentálně tam čekáme na kapacitu Pavla
dušičky a to je vlastně 1 z možných rizik,
ale tím, jak jsi říkal,
že vlastně tu frontu částečně řídí Martin,
tak by nás to jako nemělo ohrozit.
Martine.
Citu.
Ano jsem tu.
Tak takový evergreen Pavla,
takový evergreen tady.
To je, no to je každoročně levný no.
V tý firmě.
A.
Jak to vidíš tady to je riziko nějaký jak
to vidíš ty?
Záleží, jak se povedou ostatní projekty.
Jo Pavla, tam má teďka ten slovenský šato.
S tím Pavlem.
Slovenský auto store podporuju dobře,
tak se na tohlencto dostane.
Pokud nepudou dobře,
tak mě bude muset hledat ústupky.
No zatím neumíme jako odpovědět,
z hlediska tohodle.
Teď to je v.
Ano máme tu backlogu no.
Tuhle chvíli.
A dobrý je že jako.
1 za měsíc nebo by si to otáčíte no?
Hele a měli by smysl z měsíce to dát na
půl měsíc 1 14 dní, nebo to je ambiciózní?
Ale já mám jako svoje interní schůzky s
Pavlem, nebo když mě tam zvládli dojít.
1 1 jako za týden a půl za 2 týdny.
Takže jako tady ta 1 oficiální 1 za měsíc,
ale já se s ním bavím jako častěji.
Dobře, tak jo.
Jo jenom prostě se tady jako táhnout
ostatní projekty robot,
jak to táhne už minulého roku a tak dále.
Takže ono se to jako na sebe naskakuje a
potom ten ta fronta je prostě jako velká
no.
Dobře, tak jo.
Dobře tady asi víc nic víc.
Tak prosím pokračuj tedy.
Tak dalším tím bodem je facility,
tam jsme vlastně několikrát říkali,
že máme seznam nejčastějších závad a na
konci dubna zhodnotíme,
kam jsme se posunuli,
tak máme k dispozici report.
Martin má k dispozici takovej pěknej
report.
Škola.
Může ho tady ukázat,
pokud bude zájem a máme připravenou tu
trojku na biners krobota,
ale zatím ji nemáme jako odkliknutou jako
hotovo,
protože ještě jí potřebuje Martin
zvalidovat z inkem.
Jinak nevidíme UU toho tématu facilit
jako nevidíme žádný žádný riziko.
Aha.
Tak.
Tak co se týče instalace,
tak stavební příprava byla zahájena.
Tady.
Element měl do vyznačit včera místo,
kde budou ty prostupy.
Zítra to tam jedu zkontrolovat,
jestli to je jestli to je tak,
jak jsme se domluvili.
Máme domluvenou kapacitu těch dodavatelů
od elementu máme zadání na elektro a na
data to máme zkontrolovaný s Alešem
valožkem AS Martinem Čechem,
že za ně je tam vše,
co je potřeba a současně domlouváme
koordinační schůzku na místě,
kde bychom chtěli mít všechny ty profese.
To je plus Roman.
A jak jsme tady říkali, minule,
že jsme narazili na možný riziko.
My jsme to teda nepojmenovávali jako
riziko,
protože jsme si to zatím jako riziko
neviděli.
S tím posunem conwayer portu kvůli
robotiku. Tak riziko to není,
protože jsme se IS Filipem domluvili,
že se to posouvat nebude.
Zůstane to na stejně nastavené jako jako
ty ostatní 2 porty.
Takže jakoby tímto můžeme říct,
že jsme jako eliminovali to riziko a
žádný další jako riziko tam nevidíme.
Momentálně samozřejmě může tam nějaký
nastat s nějakým jako zpožděním,
ale zatím zatím jedeme podle plánu.
Co se co se týče u softwaru,
tak tam Martin říká,
Software.
že u toho 1 logu úprava vnořených svozů
tam taky máme jako problém s kapacitou,
takže tam je jako možný riziko kapacita.
V té provozní části s těmi jsme říkali,
že řešíme lepší využitelnost sportů na
příjmu,
aby jsme eliminovali ten idletime a že
vytváříme reportovací nástroj,
tak k tomu taky máme report taky ho může
Martin Martin ukázat.
A pak jsme se o tom bavili, že je možné.
Je to riziko.
Projektem, to je vlastně to,
aby byl dostatečný počet lidí na směnách
na piku,
že vy vlastně jako připravíme ten stroj
tak, aby jako ten výkon měl,
ale musí tam být dostatečný počet lidí,
aby aby jako to bylo efektivní.
Takže.
David tohle ví, nebo to nějak řeší?
Tohle má informace od vás?
Co.
S tím tedy?
AV podstatě nevím,
jestli to je něco k řešení,
je to jako řekněme každoroční problém
dělám občas jako dojedou lidi jako má li
ten projekt,
tak tak je potřebuje tam ty lidi byli a
Pak vybral.
Pojďme dál.
nevnímám to jako riziko,
když to jako o tom.
Pojbral.
Třeba takhle se o to jako oficiálně,
že se to, co se týče.
S Davidem s tím počítat.
Takhle.
Tak pojďme dál hardware.
Co se týče hardwaru,
tak tam probíhá denní týdenní kontrola.
Po poslední kontroly AI máme vytvořený
checklist o tom, jak tu kontrolu provádět?
Co se týče hardwaru,
tak objednáme ty komponenty.
Jiný riziko tam nevidíme,
nebo žádný riziko hardwaru jako nevidíme.
Produktka je to jako čistější riziko.
Okay.
Co ty milníky.
Jenom tady se podíváme rychle.
Pardon,
tady je tady teda do třicátýho 4 jo,
to bylo trojka.
A po dokončení nového modelu continuous
třeba ty 4 byl nějaký pevný check.
Jo taky zase.
Půjde.
Jak jsme říkali minule hotový hotový,
to je jak jsme říkala minula hotový,
Přejme to vás?
to je tohle? To je jako část,
který se bude jako táhnout víceméně
následujících letech a postupně to jako
dále odlehčovat. Takže asi tak.
Jasný.
Pokračuje. Jo a veliko jsi si říkala viď.
A veliko jsme říkali, že máme jenom,
je potřeba ji zvalidovat z hin cena ale
Jasný.
jako.
Máme jí hotovou.
Dobrý.
Okyroky tak tady asi a potom tady prosím
tě,
toto ještě hele zítra máte zrocených
posunu z hlediska výpadku autostoru a
tenhle objednán příprava jste tohle tohle
ty 3 ještě no tady máte.
Stavební připraveno,
zahájena to tam můžeš dát jako hotovo.
Splní super.
Hardware máme objednaný,
to tam taky můžeš dát jako hotovo a ty
výpadky.
To Martin ukáže ten report,
takže to si myslím,
že asi taky by se dalo říct, že ho to.
No zhodnocení repatia tak to nějak
zhodnotit potom asi to je krok 2.
To je hotovo.
Hotovo jo ouki roky.
Tak pojďme ptal, přeskočíme, teda dorazil,
ale kapacita příjmů.
T kulačů.
A vyšší kapacity příjmu.
Ano, co se týče navýšení kapacity příjmů,
tak, jak jsi říkal v pondělí,
jsem si byla pro schválení na na ten
přesun.
Pochopila jsem,
že náklady na přesun míra schválil.
Současně se připravuje layout a nic v tom
nově prostoru. Jak bude vypadat?
Potom budeme moct zahájit přesun.
A ještě 1.
Věc tam jako míra zmínil jako možnost.
Já jsem se na to dneska jako ptal a
provozu Davida hubra,
co si o tom myslí a to je ta možnost
otočit výtah směrem k té nové b phoše.
S tím by souvisela jako úprava layoutů.
Říkal,
Jo.
že to potřebuje probrat právě jako s
Davidem kupcem, jestli jestli,
jakoby to dává smysl, nebo ne.
Potom potom bysme to začali nějak řešit.
My už jsme to probírali,
ale my jsme to řešili,
ušetřím jakoby s kukama,
i když jsme dávali dohromady ten laub,
tak jsme říkali, jako že by to bylo dobrý.
Ale zase zavrhli jsme to,
protože si myslím, že cenově je to úplně,
jako to bude raketa.
Ale netuším, netuším jo,
takže jsme začali pracovat s tím,
To bude.
že to neprojde,
ale jako samozřejmě bylo by to lepší.
Jo jasně rozumím.
Já jsem jako chtěla vědět.
Z toho provozního pohledu,
jestli jako to dává smysl než to,
než to jakoby začnu řešit,
takže určitě tu cenu cenu zjistím s tím
jako nemám problém a pak si můžeme to
otočit ještě s mírou. Jestli je.
Tak jestli dává smysl nebo ne?
Jo jo jo jo supr tak děkuju,
to je dobrá zpráva.
To znamená otočit drata i dopravník ne,
nebo ne?
No ne.
Nebo.
Ano.
Dopravníky nejenom tak.
Jo ty kráso.
Dobře.
Tak hardware 2.
To by byla ta provozní část.
Co se týče hardwaru,
tak už tady několik týdnů říkala,
že připravujeme testování toho r seneru.
NS kenner máme,
máme ho k dispozici v chrášťanech.
V pondělí dorazil ještě ten bluetooth
adaptér abysme mohli propojit s počítačem.
Si plánujeme to s Lukášem tom jsou
otestovat pravděpodobně zítra,
ale co se týče toho hardwaru,
tak vlastně míra se vyjádřil tak,
Který.
že aktuálně nevidí důvod kupovat hardware
na zlepšení ergonomie, když jakoby.
Máme finální řešení,
jak bude ta příjmová stanice vypadat?
Takže zatím jako tu výměnu aha.
Gonomický stránky to zatím jako postavený.
V řešení je proto rozdělené pracoviště na
trojpor.
Že tam jsme říkali,
že bysme chtěli nahradit tam mobilní
stolek nebo pevný pracoviště.
On vlastně i Ondra daneš k tomu měl jako
poznámku, jestli to provoz používá.
Pravidelně nebo jenom v sezóně a jak se
to změní potom,
co se otevřou nebo co se postavěj?
Ty boční porty příjmový těch 11.
Jestli jako to tam bude potřeba nebo ne,
takže to tam ještě spolu zítra na místě s
Ondrou chceme probrat.
Pak můžu přejít na IT,
vývoj tam máme ty 3 logy.
S tím rozděleným pracovištěm souvisí ten
log příjem rozdělení AE stanic.
Co mi vlastně říkal? Dneska je Ondra,
tak provoz tam má problém jako s
propisováním aktivit, reportováním chyb,
že vlastně všechno jde na toho člověka,
který obsluhuje ten trojport.
Je tam přihlášenej jakoby na ty na ty 2
porty a ten člověk.
Se, jakoby obsluhuje ten 1.
Nebo tak jako,
takže že by tam potřebovali to trochu
jako popohnat ten vývoj,
takže ale tam to zase jako stojí na nebo.
Je to v backlogu u Pavla růžičky.
AS tím 3 logem ty dropsóny,
tak tam jsme jakoby narazili na to,
že podobnost máme tam jako podobné zadání
jako řeší Filip koeš na skalce PC,
který řeší příjem do do šatlu a procesáci
si tam s ním domlouvali sloučení pod 1
zadání, na kterém bude IT pracovat.
Takže tam.
Už už to vypadá jako dobře,
že už se na tom začne pracovat.
A tohle ještě teda to znamená,
to znamená přes tohle přes nějakou
seznamu?
Hrátler.
Tak podle.
Já jsem to tam zatím nechala,
protože jak jsem říkala,
je zatím otevřený ten hardware pro to
rozdělení pracoviště,
že tam bysme potřebovali.
Pokud by to nebyl mobilní solek.
To.
Akorát poslední.
Tam taky bychom kdyžtak potřebovali
hardware,
takže já jsem tam ještě jako nechala
otevřený bod. Nákupní seznam je možný,
že tam jako nákupní seznam nebude,
ale zatím ho tam nechávám.
Jo.
Ono se asi jestli se teda potkáte s
opravdu na place,
tak se asi pobavíte a ještě asi se
shodnete na nějakých věcech.
Ano.
Jo jo.
A tady nějaký rizika hrozby v tuhle
chvíli, tedy tady nějaká směna, že jo,
mírový,
prostě nějaké úpravy toho celýho nějaký.
Stíháte to?
Já si myslím,
že prozatím prozatím to stíháme.
O.
Já tam nevidím žádný riziko.
My jsme tam původně měli riziko,
Jo.
že se nevejdeme do úžic do zdip to jsme
tam měli v tom projektu.
No.
Tady furt je.
O tom jsme se bavili,
že no je to není to tam okomentovaný,
ale jako riziko riziko to není číselně se
tam číselně se tam vejdeme bez problémů
layout užit máme,
ten je v pořádku layout s dip ještě ještě.
Ještě na něm víte, pracuje.
Aha.
Tam tromtra nechal já to,
protože my to furt svítím to disborduju,
tak jestli to je platí nebo to neplatí to
riziko víš?
Jako řekli jsme si, že to neplatí,
ale nechala bych ho tam,
dokud nebudeme mít ty layouty,
abychom to jako měli úplně přesně
potvrzené.
Dobrý, já ho tam teda nechám,
bude to tady to potom,
když to das bodu svítí. Víš tak?
Jenom.
Ať to jako akorát.
Jo jo.
Tak dobroš OK.
Jak už to pádím tedy tady asi nic dalšího.
Jo prosím tě,
jaká míra zmiňovala ty on i skenery a
podobně to využití těch těch skenů a
tohle tam nějak.
Pamatuješ si to, jak to říkal v pondělí?
Pamatuji si to jestli myslel ty overheady.
Zatím jsem to neřešila,
No.
kdyžtak zítra na místě.
Tak tak tak no.
Super.
Tak to asi všechno děkuju.
Výrobce už něco tady ty manipulace a
podobně. Tady pár pro pro ostatní.
Ahoj, mámu pane.
Já nevim,
jestli to je kolikrát lidi si třeba,
jestli už je vlastně váš konec,
tak klidně si může někdo odpovit a můžeme
si říct třeba my 2, nebo koho to zajímáte?
Tady zůstane.
Hele já můžu jenom já můžu jenom já můžu
jenom k manipulaci.
Dobře, hele to, co potřebuješ slyšet?
Jestli můžu tak já jsem jenom rozjela v
rychlosti, ještě psala jsem to i mírovi,
ale rozjela jsem v rychlosti tendr na
nákup pro depa Plzeň,
protože jak Martina říkala,
potřebuje to relativně rychle,
takže tam máme 1 nabídky.
Už to ona už tu investici schválenou měla,
takže tam bude v průběhu příštího týdne
bude objednávka na na manipulačku do
Plzně.
To je 20 paleťáků,
všechno ostatní je pak bodem toho
schválení investičního záměru,
kterej tam vlastně?
Má má míra čeká na na druhýho míru.
Já se moc těju.
Pár potkat.
Dobře.
OK asi taková s výrobou provedu tady
někde vendy.
Tak jo hele moc moc děkujeme.
Příště už bude květen tak to bude to
velký to rebium.
Já jsem zamluvil zasedačkou galerie
šestýho třídy je Ondra i David hubr
přijede a tam to bude zase stejný dárka
rekonstruovat,
co se stalo vlastně v dubnu?
Plus milníky na květen jo zase si to
projdeme a.
Prosím tě. Příští týden David nepřijede,
má dovolenou přijedu já?
No tak to je krása.
Budem se těšit taky stejně,
neméně se budeme těšit na tebe. Jo,
takže dal jsem galerii.
Bude to zas takový dvouhodinový měsíční
review, výhled do května.
Tak jo moc děkuju za práci a.
Se uslyšíme,
případně uvidíme osobně samozřejmě.
Děkuju.
Zatím čau čau.
Čau.
OK vašku mám zůstat kvůli té manipulaci
nebo mě nepotřebujete k tomu?
Jo ano, zůstaň tady, probereme to s mírou.
Děkuju,
protože tam teďka ještě vlastně nevím,
jak se v jaký fázi je. 600% už je u míry,
nebude ještě 20% u lucky u těch 80% lucky.
Což z vás takže?
Lucky tolik posi vzala nebo zařídila.
Už jinak by to nemělo být,
nebo si dala to matka objednala,
No.
tak je v čem?
Mi?
Ten klip už asi u mě.
No tak povídej no a pak.
Jenom tam ty užit tam vypadá,
že se bude dělat jenom jako 1 bonus
chceme.
To b já w.
Ano.
Nebo.
A velice rozvíje ta převodovka.
Je to se dá taky vyměnit. To jsem se ptal,
kdyby byla tam ten setkal technika v
pondělí,
že to se dá jenom přesunout z toho
nějakého starýho.
Když bys cokoliv můžem použít na náhradní
díly. Takže.
Jinak by se vlastně vykosnu na náhradní.
No no a vy by se někam odstavit tam někam
do rohu nebo neslyšel.
Tak se ho zeptám.
Kam musíte jako odtáhnout ten vozík,
takže jsem se.
Kde si ho rozeberou?
Auto jako aktualita jestli jste slyšeli,
že?
Byli jako v pronájmu nějaký prostě ta
technika v kachšťanech pronájmu a nevím
teď, pardon, ale jestli členka je taková,
že zítra je donešená,
Která teda nevím.
vynášený a teprve bude řešit to,
jestli je potřeba jako něco koupit,
že ty pronájem nás jako chápu,
že se ukončej, že si myslím,
že to nepůjde. Když někdo říká,
že to jsou.
A že je možné,
jako že prostě bude novej požadavek
koupit cenu čekám,
nebo třeba se pořešej zvlášť.
Já se budu třeba dneska chytit,
pane místo abysme si řekli teda schválně,
kdyžtak toho projektu a pošlu odjel bill
i board, tak se tady stavím mezi třeba,
nebo to snad řešíme?
Potom Luckou víš o tom něco a třeba
lucasto psát nebo něco má to někde nevíš?
Jestli myslíš ty pronájmy,
my už jsme to řešili,
protože už do toho začala jako dloubat
Lucka hudková. Lukáš nám nasdílel v asaně.
Nějakej přímo jako task,
kde si to oni píšou,
protože ona vlastně řešila,
že oni si schvalujou,
že si schvalujou pronájmy jako sami,
bez jako podpisu asi míry nebo nevím.
Ale nicméně ty všechny stroje,
co oni mají v pronájmu,
tak oni vlastně říkají,
že na tom ušetřili dost peněz, protože.
Ten servis tam probíhal.
Potravin.
Teda, když tam budeš, prostě to jenom.
Přes ty pronájmy.
Tak se lidi, když tak jako jestli,
bude nějaký nový požadavek.
Vlastně jako řídili sami,
že jo lucko asi teda chápu.
Ano ale zatím jako o žádném novém
požadavku nevim vy vlastně to,
co pro gurment říkal,
že je to nerentabilní,
Stroj.
že to tam mají strašně dlouho,
tak jako není pravda.
Vozíky tam mají maximálně od nějakýho
léta 24 nebo nějak tak.
A vlastně Lukáš připravoval tabulku,
že to řešil s Davidem.
Asi to řešil IS Ondrou na nějakým jako
vyčíslení,
kolik se ušetřil na těch servisech,
protože jediný, co se tam jako platilo,
tak bylo maximálně nějaká jako práce.
Ale jinak tam byly škodní události.
No.
A tyhlety věci,
takže jako tam všechno tam jako vlastně
jsme na tom víceméně jako ušetřili.
Tuhle tabulku máš máš tabulku od Lukáš
donkci teďka Lucka říká nějakou tabulku?
Chtěl bych si vědět.
Tak jestli jestli máme?
Hele jak jsou náklady na údržbu
manipulační techniky v tom projektu.
Tady ano.
Přirovnat to vlastně nesdílím také ani na
ten dům navetně nákupy, pardon nákup.
No v tom no v tom projektu nákup
manipulační techniky,
Jo nákup na.
tak projekt managementu je náklady na
údržbu manipulační techniky a tam jsem
hodila odkaz na na soubor.
Promiň jenom.
Rozdíl no.
Nevím, jestli tam budeš mít přístup.
Míra ho tam má když,
tak ho tam hodím i tobě vašku,
aby ses do toho dostal.
Byla tady tahle.
Asi seš tady tady to je, vidíš to opery.
Kdyžtak přímo přidali.
Když se budeš podívat.
Třeba.
Zkus to otevřít, jestli se tam dostaneš.
Můžu.
Nevím, zkusíme. Já právě jsem vložil,
jak seděl s Ondrou v kanceláři,
jak tam právě vlastním kupcem,
až to budu teda řešit a že vlastně ty
čísla se mu nezdaly.
Jenom že to budu teda řešit,
tak já mám aktuálně. Jak jsou pro vás?
Jo jo.
Zkus zkus to ještě 1 teď už ho tam máš.
Nemůžu a to se budu prostě odpusť,
ať to zkusí zeptat,
co jí pořešit a danchtak požádám,
že nejsou úplně. To je 1 věc.
No jo a pak 2 věc je teda celá.
Tady jsou ty čtečky, tiskárny to nevím,
To chápu chápu.
jestli něco máte něco ochotu žáka,
aby se tam i obětí pěkná družice kulturní
rozšíření dala si 400.
Hele ano on míra míraopa tam jako dal
požadavky na 14 do půlky dubna na 14 do
Takže to budu řešit to?
července, ale já už jsem hned zpočátku,
jako se Terezy ptala,
jestli jako je to potřeba rozdělovat,
jestli to oni potřebujou jako v
souvislosti s 24 7,
nebo to potřebujou do sezóny a ona mi
tvrdila, že to stačí do sezóny,
takže jsem si z toho vzala,
že to stačí koupit někdy v tom červenci a
teď vlastně ona říká,
že to potřebuju urychleně.
Bylo.
Podě,
co zařídíme pohoda a nebo jestli prostě.
Já jsem neviděl, jestli vy teda vidíte,
že je něco špatně se děje špatně,
nebo je vidět, co máme zkus,
tak mi dejte prosím vědět asi na tebe,
nebo?
Jo.
Piva úctu nebo lokální.
Že jsem vůbec nevěděl,
že teď jsem docela anton Tomáše lada ten
nápočet, kolik vlastně to bude tak info,
jak k těm čtečkám,
že ještě Filip dělá nějaký výpočet a
každému to vyšlo nějak jinak.
Čili jiná technika já úplně vám zařídit
jako právě do těch skladů,
kterým se dá vůbec neposílám mi napsal,
takže jsem může jít dál jako.
Či já jsem.
Dal požadavky na ty sklady tam za.
Kolik oni mají vlastně čteček?
Tak to taky bude na to zase nějak.
Ty se mají říct,
Jsou to.
kolik oni chtějí objednat čteček a jako
porovnání,
co kde tě v tom nějak byla podobná, že jo,
ale právě jsem zrovna pořád někdo,
Ano ano.
kdo má číslo, ale v těch kasárách to není.
Hele já jsem ti házela ten projekt
loňskej nebo neházela.
Teď nevím.
Takže ruská dostává dost času,
aby to zkontrolovalo jako já?
Koupíte?
Právě že tam odměny už se to dávalo v
minulém roce přecedněný,
kolik se ani na to ptám znovu,
ale tam je prostě jenom 1 task na toho
Tomáše nějak že ho čteček a tiskáren a
není tam vůbec, nebo tam vůbec nic. Aha.
Jasně.
Ale.
Ale přidala jsem ti projekt loňskej nákup
se čeká tiskáren,
z toho se můžeš inspirovat.
Vašek tam je v tom projektu,
takže když by se mi povedlo otevřít,
tak my jsme tam přímo dávali jako
inventura čítače, který jako Filip dával.
A oni ten Tomáš třeba aktuální čísla no a
60.
No jasně.
Takže ano? Určitě, určitě to dává smysl,
jak jsem ti psala, dávalo by smysl,
ať rovnou projedou i tiskárny,
prostě ať projedou,
kolik toho maj a můžou si můžou si jako
napsat. Kolik si myslí,
že by toho potřebovali,
ale stejně potom jako loni.
Loni to bylo tak, že jako v tý no,
no a loni to bylo tak,
Jo ten zubař mi psal,
že potřeboval jenom ty čtečky takhle
nenapadlo,
že jo se můžem udělat i vy tiskár.
že stejně jako chrašťany řekli,
že potřebujou tiskárny a Filip řekne
podle mejch čísel nepotřebujou,
pak se stejně dokupovali někdy v
listopadu, jo, takže.
Spíš nebyl Lucka o té ploše.
To jsem já, tak ten právě ten náš procesu,
ale.
Tak jo.
A tady to ten ta.
Takže.
No tohle já to zajímalo, to jsem právě,
že já jsem.
Zase jako včera.
Tak něco je.
Taky to to je přitom předání toho dneska
prezentovala,
že to je hotové a pak jsem zjistil tohle
a to máš?
Napsal třeba nějaký pes starý data? Jo,
hlavně tam je,
takže to je to co tam pak píšu na 1.
Komentáře měl Tomáš malín dat aktuální ty
požadavky tady ahoj, potřebujeme,
já se podívej, hele tady terka, já vím,
to je dneska čerstvý v pohodě.
To je to, co jsem říkala, že mi říkala,
že to potřebuje,
Jo.
že to stačí jako s tím centrálním nákupem
a najednou to nestačí. Jo,
Tak.
Teďka teda spíš jenom pro míru,
abych to nebyl úplně jako lesní včela.
takže to je tak jako nový info.
Co ta míra teďka by měl to,
protože že jo on teda něco řeší.
Teďka do toho hází takovou tu kaši typu
souhlasím, bude mít data poslouchá říkám,
aby aby prostě v tom nebyl jako smutný,
co by se doporučoval teďka.
No, tak určitě, já jsem.
Já jsem mu psala tu inventuru.
Určitě jako.
Ještě 1.
By to prošli tu inventuru.
Tímhle tu AS kým co?
Inventuru čtečky čtečky,
tiskárny to už vlastně míra vykop,
takže teďka prostě počkat,
co co budou chtít.
Chápu ne ten účet tu inventuru ti ten
procesář, já pak jenom předám,
co mi pošlu zklady ty inventury jako tady
to máte, co jste chtěli zařídit po mě?
Tak tam už by se mohlo nějaký prostě
prostřední.
Hele je to tady hodím.
Jinak pak zase mi ještě říkal ten Tomáš,
nebo co říkal ten bumeč,
že Filip kouč už dával za úkol lukášovi?
Jsme tam vypromentovat ten už dávání do
tý čtečky. To je, jak jsem si říkal,
že jsme si udělali poprvý, že mi přijde,
že na průmyslu procesáci s dokumentem,
tak ať dělají napřímo tak jenom tady,
protože to stejně takhle funguje na přímo.
Tam.
To byla lucko neměla viď?
Ne Filip řešil maximálně kolik licence s
prokrumentem jinak čtečky jako ne.
Třeba to špatně pochopil. Hele,
takhle jenom takhle moje vnímání teďka z
toho, co tady bavíme,
že úplně jako teďka probíráno má jako
buďto připravený,
nebo prostě tam je spousta ještě
proměnnejch,
kterýho by si potřeboval ujasnit a dělat
tak jo, nebo.
No já chápu,
že teď si prostě dělá ten nutné.
A co je potřeba objednat to množství dá
nějak to prostě.
AU tebe.
Program hele u tebe v tom musí jako sejít.
Asi teda vý že jo.
Turín vysoká podobně.
Ano.
Za 2 podměr.
By měla být půlky typu hele ruka chcete
tyhle? DDA řeknete, je nesmysl,
Třeba.
jako že vlastně oni si můžou říct,
co chtěj těm nezatý hravý známky,
vzdušný tohleto a pak tady musí bejt.
Někdo to přesně míra, uvidíme,
co si řeknou, já si to třeba vím,
kdo přijde, že nevěděl,
V knížce.
že tady to mám zařídit. Já to čísla.
Proto sem včera byla otázky,
že jo v pohodě.
Sport.
Já bych chtěl vlastně.
Hele míro,
já tady já tady sdílím ten loňský projekt
a vlastně loni to vykopnul jako Filip
filipko, když prostě obepsal sklady,
nebo tady prostě v tom tasku hodil ještě
na senec chrášťany úžit se zdiby TC,
ať prostě tam napíšou,
co maj co potřebujou.
Takže oni to tady jako psali psali i co
by chtěli jako doobjednat.
Můžeš mi dát? Můžeš prosím,
jestli máš tenhle tohle a samo,
jestli můžeš dát jako tyhle teda asany
klidně tady do tý letošní tam?
Do popisu my.
Já jsem ti tam hodila přímo celej ten
projekt, tak já to tam k tomu hodím.
Pak tam byl ještě 1 task,
aby si sklady napsaly náhradní díly,
co potřebujou a ty jsme nerozporovali tam
prostě. Pokud si napsali,
že chtějí 100 rezervních baterek,
tak tam už jsme jako moc neměli,
jak to rozporovat.
Takže jako součástí toho centrálního
nákupu byly ty nový čtečky? To,
jak jsem říkala,
prostě bylo čtečka na rameník s držákem s
fingers cannerem s baterkou navíc a pokud
si o ní napsali,
že potřebuju třeba 100 nárameníků,
200 fingers kenderu a tak,
tak prostě jsme jim to ne fingers cannerů,
ale těch stripů,
tak jsme jim to jako nakoupili.
Tyhlety spotřební jako díly.
Hele to hodíme, kam tady máš tu jo.
A není to málo a není to málo.
Počet.
Jo dobře, tak.
Ale tady teďka už to ti dá třeba nějaké
věci zítra Ondra. Vzhledem k tomu,
že budu proveden nějaký nějaký čísla a
jako ty zákupný body?
Jo teďka tohlencto jako zkouším vysosat
jo.
A lucko vitamírová role,
jak jsi měla ty prostě říct?
Hele to vy nepotřebujete nějaký fix
scandy babla úplně kdo zapadá do koncepce?
Nebo ne?
Jakože mám zhodnotit,
jestli jako to co chtěj, je relevantní.
Setkání.
Třeba ty čtečky, že oni řekli,
chceme tohle tohle a tys to jako
zjišťovala a vlastně si zjistila,
jaký informace, který je docela důležitý,
Čeho vás?
že jo typy modelů končí výroba máme někde
ještě skladem nějaký šedi a šeďáky a
podobně. Tak to mám taky dělat.
Ano tam jsem mu jako říkala,
že právě ty čtečky je potřeba řešit co
nejrychleji kvůli tomu,
že tam končí ten prodej.
O tom jsme jako spolu mluvili,
takže si když,
tak pokud by bylo nějaké větší množství,
tak si zařídit tu skladovou zásobu.
Takže jestli teda prodeje končí už
dvacátýho 4 tak mě prosím teda trošku
pošlete teda nějaký ty kontakty na ty
firmy,
jak jsem vás prosím vás i před 2 týdnama
při tom předání nemám jediný kontakt na
žádnou firmu,
jestli teda je to najednou urgentní a je
potřeba to udělat dneska.
Nebo z vy, která?
Najednou je to urgentní,
tak mi prosím dejte nějakej kontakt,
teda komu mám zejtra zavolat.
A řešilo se to přes to přes prokurment,
tak já ti já ti jako dám kontakt přímo
Takže právě,
takže já s tou firmou nebo vůbec já s tou
jako na jimte.
firmou jako nekomunikuju já?
Já jsem teď se zmatenej se omlouvám.
No jako já na ní kontakty mám oni o mně
vědí,
ale jako ten tendr a tyhle ty věci jsme
řešil.
Lukáš smetana s nima ale jako samozřejmě
jako.
Dobře, takže patřil kontakt.
Ty stejně ty stejně jako pokud nevíš ty
počty,
Parťáky jsme tam.
tak s nima momentálně teďka nemáš co
řešit.
Která potřebuje nějakého parťáka.
Za mě prostě.
Na 1 to dám Lukáš tetara jo parťák pro
míru.
Lukáš smetana to byl loni,
takže si myslím,
že by to byl taky kontakt na in tak jako
nemám problém ti poslat, ale říkám prostě.
Myslím si, že pokud jako nejsou ty počty,
pokud jako Filip nebo Tomáš neřekne,
Tady mám s těmi glubový prosím.
tohle je ten počet,
který musíme nakoupit tak vlastně jako ty
nemáš co jim jako říct, protože ty nevíš,
jestli budeš potřebovat těch 4,
50 nebo 200.
Lukáš Lukáš na to rád,
protože pak nějak jo.
Žádný data Lukáš letac snad jo jinak,
když to sním info tím a tiskárnami od
Filip pak už je schovaná schůzka na
pondělí nějaká sing s nutní,
takže asi v pondělí se zase dozvím a
dozvíme něco novýho. Prosím tě,
přepočtu asi, jestli bys mohl v tý ruce,
máš to lucko tuto schůzku?
Tu už nemám,
ale klidně klidně tam můžu bejt.
Jo třeba nějaký paní hlas,
já nevím třeba poslouchat jo nějaký
Jo.
doplněný.
Výrobce potřeboval bezprodukce,
ať v tom případě máš jako nějakej jako.
Jo jo.
A pro mě to není potřeba.
Proč?
Hodně se.
Lucka ona ona tu historii tak jenom jo.
Takhle,
takže když to shrnu parťákem pro diskuzi
je Lukáš smetana?
Jsou 2/3.
Jo,
já se ho zeptám teda jestli nemá nějaký
info, co mají tu ránu?
Ty má ty člověky a díky.
Píše o židleny sakra.
Což je vlastně s tou, kam smetanou úcty,
nebo ty potřeba kontaktovat.
By asi dobré mu říct,
že to agent mu přebíráš nebo přebírá
vlastně víra.
Odpucky si to jako říct jo dobře.
Já vám to řeknu dneska.
Muzika se podívám do kanceláře a tam sedí.
Ruskou bude s tebou.
Dobře, jo?
A manipulačního techniku,
teda za programu ten look.
Lucka jo lucko zeptám.
Co.
Pane další technika za prokordit Lucie ta
nevím jak se jmenuje.
Lucka hudková no.
100.
Jsou vlastně 2 parťák.
Jo jo.
Ještě něco,
aby se cítil víc komfortněs teď.
Ale Lucka Lucka vomírovi ví my jsme
vlastně jako na začátku,
Dobrý jo to jo to.
když jsme jako říkali o té změně,
tak tam Lucka byla.
Point.
Dobře.
Jestliže se ti ještě vy něco na mohl.
Nebo ty tam není něco?
Ale poslala jsem ti číslo na pana
stejskala z emtecu.
Případně ještě email.
Buď primárním faktákem,
nebo tohleto jo a dovedete se,
případně to?
Tak budu asi rádi za jakou pomoc?
Ale asi asi ne,
asi proběhne ta inventury a ty jsou teda
v nějakým okamžiku sejdou od těch lidí z
těch skladů od někoho,
kdo to dělá inventuru.
No, já jsem teda takhle vím, že nám říkáš,
to už tam asi dneska dneska poslal.
Lukáš tam sám.
A už třeba tohle a to jsem dal jako na
šéfy těch skladů. Nevím,
jestli to tam udělá. Předpokládám,
že to přepošlu.
3.
Respektive to je jaký měla teda napíšu,
že inventuju plus ten mo dat a míra oba
Jo tak jako tam.
tam napíše vlastně jenom,
co chce objednat,
že vlastně tak vám napíšu bokem a není ta
inventura, tak na to ti zase.
Neodpluví, že jo.
OK, což je až to nebude, tak tady bude,
nebo jestli tak vidíte.
Jo ale oni to oni to hele oni to vždycky
dělaj užit se speciálně tak,
Že to mělo být už všechno.
že napíšou kolik toho maj a kolik toho
chtěj.
A pak už je jako otázka na jinejch lidech
to vlastně není ani jako na tobě,
aby si řekl, kolik jako kolik,
jako toho ty koupíš?
Japonska.
Bych řekl, že já mám třeba takové dikovat.
Ona tvrdého, pokud to nedáš,
takhle neusvítnul.
1 taková nějaká směna teď do poslala,
to bylo, jak jsem pochopil živelník,
že jo,
ty servisy a podobně se tam dělaly samy,
že jo bez schválení míry, a to přesně.
Odrůžky se myslím servisy u vás fr 4
servisy nějakých těch vozíků nebo co to
je to co ta modrá jede a vzhledem k tomu
co to vím jakoby.
Já jsem.
Obecně obecně jakoby je to změna najednou,
že to někdo uchopí a bude to řešit
vlastně centrálně do poslánce to děláme
každý sám takhle a to je už tohle.
To je jenom změna pro ty lidi.
Někdo udělal centrální, že jo,
po to je ta změna,
že se tam dělá něco jinak.
V tom procesu oproti předchozím letům v
případě servisu manipulačky nákup pane
plačká čehokoliv.
Jo.
Hele kdyžtak co se týče tý inventury,
tak v tom projektu loňským tam jako já.
Já nevím co ten mír a tím jako myslí,
že jsem stahovala informace ze všech
skladů prostě.
Já jako nemám nikde seznam kde jsou jako
kolik čteček jsem je na kterejch skladech
jediný, co tak to udělal Lukáš,
tam se že vyexportoval ze soty,
kolik prostě máme licencí a na základě
toho tolik máme jako čteček jsou v tom VT
jsou v tom TC, není to rozlišený,
ale po těch skladech.
A tady jako vidím že míra.
Takže když se to dělá prostě telefon
skladu a mohla se ti předat,
tak jako nevím fakt, co tím myslí,
protože tady v tom starým projektu,
když si to vezmu,
tak oni tady jenom hodili tabulku,
kolik toho maj a kolik toho potřebuju
objednat.
Ale jako za mě ta inventura je potřeba
dělat každej rok,
protože ta čtečka si ti může rozbít.
Můžeš jí vyřadit a tak podobně prostě
jako a my do tohodle jako nevidíme.
Vedejte nám tu i tady po.
Roce na tu dobu ne.
Pravidlo asi fakt dobrý,
ať tam je nějakej člověk.
Ten sklad perfektně funguje.
Lukáš tasa za rachet že jo.
Takže lukásnou psal lukášnou psa 2 jestli
je někde méně stavěnej a vy oni dělali ty
Ano tam jako není problém.
věci?
Teď to chápu správně,
tak to úplně není jako stejný, nebo?
Živočalní.
No.
Hele tady sdílím ještě jestli to vidíte
tak vlastně.
Protožeová ambice není tam lítat po
skladu,
že jo počítat to není úplně mírová ambice
jako jo.
Pardon.
Tak jestli vidíte,
tak vlastně tohle mi poslali zdi 2 lúzice.
Jo kolik mají prostě funkčních,
kolik mají nefunkčních a kolik chtějí
koupit?
Tak málo.
A vlastně tohle to se ani jako nekupovalo.
Že to Filip prostě řek, že ne?
Že to není potřeba.
Takže jako jestli míra opat myslí tady
ten přehled,
tak tenhle ten přehled jako za mě úplně.
Stačí.
Nebo je úplně na prd.
Tam.
9.
Haló haló.
Jo jo slyším tak jako nemyslím si,
že těch zařízení je tolik to jako my jsme
s Lukášem tam jsou hledali 1 den prostě
80 tiskáren po chrášťanech,
takže jako já si myslím,
že to jako není nic složitýho prostě
spočítat kolik je čteš a kolik je funkční
čteček.
Ale se tomu věřit tady v tý tabulce.
Co myslíš?
No jako jinej.
Nemáme výstup,
to už je pak jako jedině že tam jako
pojedeš to tam spočítat prostě jo.
Chápu.
To chápu to asi nevypočítá, že jo,
ale dobře. No tak normálně mě jde o to,
Vůbec?
že Lukáš jo toho psa tam má krásnou
tabulku, že jo,
která má vypadá dobře a tady máš nějaký
nějaký chudý příbuzný, že jo,
kde tabulky je čau.
No tu tabulku už nemá,
protože ta tabulka byla někde na
sharepointu ona zmizela,
takže jsme se snažili dát nějakou jako
jinou tabulku dohromady a takovou tu
krásnou, co jsi viděl loni,
tak ta už taky jako není.
Tak právě proto udělal ten export z toho
sathy, aby jako jsme zjistili,
kolik teda těch čteček je to se mírovi
všechno posílala.
No jestli ještě něco měli,
tak já už asi potřebuju. Vidíte sama?
No dobrý,
asi všechno mám v paleartici tyčkám no.
Hele, jak říkám prostě,
kdybys cokoliv jako potřeboval,
Tiskárna přímo.
tak jako napiš já ti pošlu,
jestli ještě něco prostě jako najdu,
ale teďka mě nic jako nenapadá.
Radost fyzicky tý test ještě ten Lukáš
smetana, že musí s vámi věci.
Dobře, tak jo, díky zatím všechno.
Tak jo mějte se ahoj.